what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the game before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell to be notified of my
daily videos while you're at it guys if
you have watched two or more of my labs
and you do not subscribe we've okay beef
people so a couple announcements before
we start the show the first being that
we have two girls the first being Pearl
daily and the second being just pearly
Clips make sure you go subscribe to both
up of that we have a four membership
tiers the first is it lets you be a part
of the live five dollar a month tier the
next you get behind the scenes Vlogs and
you also get to be a part of our Discord
community board is going to be a big
part of the next month we are really
focusing on our Discord members so make
sure you sign up for the second the
third tier you get to connect with me on
social media and the fourth tier you get
a one-on-one call with me once a month
helped so many people get to ten
thousand twenty thousand thirty thousand
subscribers on YouTube that is probably
where you value for your dollar so make
sure you sign up for my my fourth tier
on top of my Instagram it's just dot
pearly things it's Shadow band right now
so you have to type in the whole thing
but make sure you go follow that
um also I they took away my first tick
tocks but I have a fourth and a fifth
Tick Tock so go follow just pearly
things dot full just pearly things dot
five because I am on my last account
warning on just probably things forward
but don't worry just probably think six
is coming soon um
on top of that thank you for 100k last
stream we hit 400 000 subscribers
um we don't know what we want to do K we
have had some suggestions that
I
no we can't no no no no no so
um but but in the comments what you
think we should do for 500k
um on top of that we're gonna do a
members live in the next couple of weeks
and DM Eddie if you want to come on the
show so we have a lovely panel so how
does everyone go around
um say your name your age your
relationship status and fun fact either
that you know or about yourself so you
start and then go around hi everybody uh
my name is Paris I'm 31 goal and my fun
fact is I'm a qualified professional tap
dancer oh that's so fun can you teach me
sure okay we'll talk we'll talk
I'm Gracie backray uh 30. fun fact
nothing fun I can't think of one
no sorry can't uh what's next
status oh single yeah
hello everyone my name's Alex
um I'm 28 and fun fact
um I used to be in Buenos Aires
where's that in Argentina
oh and to plug it too
honey we just had a really good live
show check us out on Instagram and
YouTube MILF and honey podcast yeah I
was just on it um yesterday or no Sunday
Sunday yeah it was fun it was good
hi I'm Maxi Johnson from the MILF and
honey podcast I'm 32 and relationship
status is married
fun fact is
saying is that fun yeah I sing yeah
we'll see you wanna okay I'll holler at
you
uh hi my name is Kim and fun fact
uh uh fun fact is I was in one of the
Harry Potter films
[Music]
wait really yeah I didn't how did I know
that Half Blood Prince was the worst one
the one where Dumbledore dies what were
you I was one of the students I was like
14 at the time
[Music]
um I'm toasty one third of MILF and
honey podcast I'm 32. haven't said that
age out loud
I'm 32 I'm single and fun fact is
I'm allergic to heat it's like I knew
you was going to say that yeah yeah I
knew she was gonna say that you're
allergic to heat yeah I wonder I'm
really hot I get sunburned so it's kind
of like
it's not the same area tomorrow
Yeah Eddie
um from the domino effect you don't know
me obviously hit me up coming to show
um fun fact how old are you 28.
sorry
[Laughter]
so today's topic I actually got from the
lovely ladies here um at their live show
Sunday
um so my question to you guys because
you guys asked me this this weekend
what is a modern woman and so start
there go around and then yeah I would
say that Modern Woman is
a woman that wants to have her cake and
eat it personally I think
why do you think that
who me yeah
um because I noticed that whenever
there's like these debates and stuff
they pick all the
things that they want that um benefits
them and then when the coins on the
other side then you've got to the
benefits of a man what like roles at the
man play the women all of a sudden have
an argument against it and it's like
you're never consistent of your
arguments it's like it keeps changing
it's changing from each
why do you love him no because I was
thinking I thought it was funny meme
where it's like it showed like the most
blue haired like pink feminist right
she's like raging out in the streets but
the second she's in a burning building
she's like oh the innocent woman who
needs the man to help her because like
that's what she's precise I was like
yeah it's so funny
um I think a modern day woman is someone
who
doesn't necessarily who takes on roles
that is maybe for a man but
is but most of the time is due to
circumstances you know a lot of the time
it's due to circumstances I don't think
any woman actually wants to be a modern
day woman agreed yeah Justin yeah
interesting circumstances yeah I think
it's hard to say but I think for me a
modern day woman is someone who wants to
do what they want when they want and
doesn't want to feel guilty for it I
think that's fair
[Music]
I think a Monday woman is a woman who
has the freedom to choose
to
um
to indulge or go down roots that maybe
weren't available to her before
[Music]
um but I
I think I think a shift happens when her
priorities change but then sometimes
you know actions have consequences and I
think sometimes they're not always aware
of what those consequences are
like you want to talk about something
specific this is General this is just
general the warm-up right now oh um
a modern day woman for me is a woman
that works hard
but
in her working hard it may give her a
sense of entitlement
and a modern day woman may not even
necessarily be a woman
[Laughter]
did you go I agree with Paris I think
woman is somebody who
wants to have her cake and eat it I
think she's extremely lost and confused
in what she wants I think only when it
benefits her as she because
we want to work but then at the same
time we don't want to work we want
somebody to look after us yeah that's
why I said it's due to circumstances not
always not always circumstance I would
say experience more than circumstances
okay I think a lot of modern day women
um base their beliefs on what's
happening in the past that has nothing
to do with them
oh other people's yeah yeah yeah but
that's life anyway everyone on Instagram
bases their beliefs on other people's
problems exactly I think as well we're
in like an era now where it's really
conflicting information about what a
woman's meant to like be yeah we've got
certain uh role models and like the
entertainment industry that are pushing
us whole like
um what's the word liberating lifestyle
yeah like you can do what you want and
they're not talking about the
consequences of it
um and then you've got like maybe like
your grandparents era where they're
teaching you all Traditional Values so
yeah it's a big it's very confusing I
think if you're stuck between that it's
like you're almost like what what do I
follow this is what everyone in the
world but other sides of my family home
is telling me and if I look at like
traditionally what's happening it's
completely different so but those um
those women that sing all those songs
and everything they don't practice what
they preach there oh yeah I know so true
but in terms of like the videos and
stuff and and what they're wearing and
the
everything hanging out like
they're doing that that's not the trip
for me personally I don't even know as a
celebrity quote unquote you have to also
be realistic that you take on that
responsibility or that knowledge that
you do influence people but I feel like
as an individual you shouldn't let those
people influence you you should have a
mind of your own yeah but I think that's
so gone I was gonna say I think that's
that's a bit of the double standard that
you want to be in the Limelight and with
that comes the responsibility to
influence yeah but then you don't want
to be held responsible for True You're
influence true yeah so and also where
women are of an age of Olden age so I
think that's easier for us to say but if
you're a younger girl like say 12 13
listen yeah to this and growing up with
this this is this is all you know yeah
but the likes of some of those girls who
put those songs out they don't let their
kids listen to it yeah so as a parent
I'm a parent I wouldn't let my children
like for instance my children don't
watch TV during the week I control what
they do and how often they watch it
that's good and there definitely is an
element of control but still but there's
only so much control you can have your
parents and I know that when my child my
child goes to school yeah
have you ever have you ever thought
about like homeschooling because you
can't yeah oh my God yes because I I've
always thought that like the schools are
so bad and where I'm from Chicago they
took away grades
they took away yeah they took away
grades recently didn't just parcel fell
I don't know my mom just told me they
took away grades but Chicago's Chicago
is known for having like [ __ ] schools
like that's what we're and I'm like with
the this in the schools I'm like I
almost don't even want I don't agree
yeah and the thing is you don't know
what they're teaching your kids at
school you know or like how they're
treating your younger girl I was like at
this Leisure Center and I saw um they
were like shuffling in a bunch of like
five and six-year-olds and the way they
spoke to these kids was like so
atrocious I was like oh my God if their
parents were here like if I was their
parent I'd be like don't speak to my kid
like that
you know I wish I had the time to
homeschool but as a modern day woman
yeah I have to work I'll be honest
though even if I was like a traditional
I know what my skill sets are and I
don't think teaching is one of it so I
wouldn't deceive to think I would be
good at teaching I definitely couldn't
do math yes
sir I thought when there's such a small
that young age everything is learning
you know like even a trip to the grocery
shop yeah you're teaching them how to be
like if there's a line to teach them how
to be patient yeah yeah yeah
um even confidence building like okay
you pay for it there's so much learning
in everything just that's true we are
conditioned to think learning is in the
classroom just yeah there's so much more
good yeah there's like a thing called
World schooling
um I don't really know much about it but
I guess you just take your kid out into
the world and you're like is the world
learn yeah we all had to start somewhere
so there was the world had to have been
a classroom at one point yes yes
what do you think Eddie what's a modern
day woman she's not remember me yeah
I think he's gonna hit the nail in the
head though I I think the modern day
woman is selfish
I think a modern a woman like you said
wants to have a cake and eat it
motherly woman it lacks accountability
motherly woman hates men I don't know I
said Eddie you're getting quite
comfortable back there yeah I don't like
the fact that you're back there come do
me son I just want to say I want to be
looking at you exactly yes say it with
your chest Ellie yeah I just think of
other woman is the things I mentioned um
quite problematic
um the main source of the problem to
modern day relationships oh my God
a delusional narcissistic self-entitled
feminist who shits on men for her poor
choices and she was so happy when she
was so proud
everyone came to get ready I was already
ready
sorry what were you gonna say
I know he's gonna get at me but
sometimes do you not feel like sometimes
some women are behaving the way they are
because men are not actually being
traditional men anymore oh my God yeah
yeah preach I think that's part of it
not in a I'm not saying in a negative
way that oh like you're not a man but I
feel like you you know how you said on
you said on the live show that you know
you guys we should be thankful to you
people because you guys have given us
the opportunities like we have right but
do you feel like you guys have even
managed us let's say what you're saying
is true but do you feel like you guys
have managed us as the men you're meant
to be let me ask them one question who
creates those men that you're talking
about facts women right so that's your
answer there because the thing is right
you're saying about oh men being
traditional men
but but here's the thing though right if
you tomorrow if every woman in the west
was like you know what let's take sex
for example you know what I'm not having
sex with you unless we're in a committed
relationship every man would start or
would start acting correctly I no I
agree with you so so in regards to okay
what is the minimum standard that a man
has to bring in order to get a woman
as women you all set the rules and
that's what's it on the live show so I
did say that men conform to the
standards that female set exactly so if
your standards are low
you just played into our biological
imperative we just want to have sex and
keep its moving if you don't control how
you
um demand sex then men don't have to do
that so the the problem with Society now
is that women want this or I'm a mother
woman I can do what I like I can sleep
with as many men as a man can sleep with
women what is that do you end up
pregnant the man doesn't want to stay
around the man leaves for whatever
reason then you're raising a single
parent you're raising a child by
yourself you put your kid at every
statistical disadvantage by raising them
by himself plus boy simply women can't
raise men so now you raise that man that
you talk about that you don't like but
then it's men's fault but then you have
the choice of who to let in but then
it's still a man's fault the thing is
there's nothing wrong with making those
decisions like that like we live in a
free Society right part of being a
modern woman is being able to choose
what roads you want to go down yeah but
then if you Cho if you go down the
modern the modern path don't ask for a
traditional man yeah I was going to say
how do you expect to have a traditional
man if you're trying to break every rule
of a traditional woman exactly yeah well
and that's a other thing is like I'll
always hear like there's this book
called why men love [ __ ] and like
girls read it yeah
girls girls girls read it and they try
to like inflate their value because
they'll like they'll sleep around or get
in a certain position or whatever and
then they'll say oh if you just raise
your standards but you can't like sell a
used Honda Civic at BMW prices the men
aren't stupid
you love that life
I don't know much about cars
I had a Honda Civic you have any girls
who are entitled in this little [ __ ]
yeah but this but I that you saw a [ __ ]
you're coming to me like I want a high
value man it's like who the [ __ ] do you
think you are yeah but I also think that
there are some men there are there are
some men that are spoiling the market
because it's giving this with these
women that are half like are naked look
good yeah you're giving them this
entitlement because you're giving them
the attention and you're giving them the
money you're paying for their bills
you're paying for this so the next guy
they meet they're going to want that
standard as well and they think they're
entitled to it because that's what's
been given to them for however many
times that's your own individual lack of
self-awareness because and a problem
with a lot of women now is that you
forget that men are dogs so you might
have a guy who's like a 10 who sleeps
with a girl that's like a free and now
you think you're a 10 because you slept
for 10. no I'm talking about the girls
that are 10.
I'm talking about the girls that you may
not want to marry but you'd class that
as a test I'll be honest the girls the
girls that are 10 are getting married
they're getting married 100 they're
getting married okay tens in terms of
those things the overall package yeah oh
you're talking about that's what I'm
saying so okay are you talking about the
Instagram girl the girls the girls but
not wifey they'll find a simp
yeah that's true but what yeah because
because I do think that men say oh yeah
you know you're gonna get banged but
you're not gonna get married not every
modern woman that wants to get married
so you banging them and giving them what
they want is actually all they're after
so that's what I'm saying in terms of
just repeating that cycle I don't think
that's completely correct because the
majority of women still want to get
married and have kids
yeah because they'll say like I don't
need a man and then but I want a man and
so I'll say okay what type of guy with
you would you want and a lot of times
start with saying oh I don't want to get
married and then when they describe the
guy that they want I say okay so if that
guy was interested in marrying you would
you want to get married and they say yes
and so it's like the problem is the guys
they want just don't want to marry them
because I thought part of the multi-day
woman was that they're more career
driven they're more they don't really
want to have children and get married it
was that they want to have children get
married but they don't want it to hinder
anything from a statistical standpoint
yeah women by and large don't want the
traditional family unit yeah yeah so I
literally searched this stuff up like
it's something like 60 60 70 of women
still want to get married okay but
basically you want to get married on
your own terms yeah that kind of thing I
think I think what I think what's become
more of the the normative culture for a
lot of modern women is that they use the
years up to the age of 30 to pursue
their career heavily and then they get
to 30 and they realize you know and it's
a real thing you know bilateral clock
and go oh well if I'm gonna have kids I
kind of need to start planning for it
now yeah and then and what happens is
they start prioritizing having the
family and stuff which is fair enough
but then they start asking for the
different kind of man so what they were
asking for before was the attractive guy
that all the other girls wants maybe the
rappers whatever the hot guy all this
it's all good looking all this right and
then they get to you know 30 30s or
whatever and they're like yo that guy
was fun but he wasn't gonna be
commitment to work I just want a nice
guy I do the same thing guys do the same
thing though guys do the same thing but
the game is different for men yeah
I don't care who it is uh can you see
because at the end of the day in their
mind it's just a knot and that's it 100
what's wrong with us they get old dog
I'm making the point he's making men do
the same thing and as they get older
they then start um making better choices
in the women that they're sleeping with
and who they would like to have as a
wife
but there's a difference though for men
right the game is different for men
because if a guy is progressing in
himself in his life in his career in his
steps right him getting older right he
can he has the option to choose the girl
that he was just going to fool around
with or to choose the more if he's
looking for like a family traditional
sense support he also has that
optionality simply meant increase of
value over time whilst women decrease in
value over time whoa no that's that yeah
that's great I agree that yeah so can I
just ask can a modern day woman turn
back to into a traditional woman so you
can be a traditional she can be a
traditional woman in practice but in
terms of in
I think there are some I think there are
some things that
a traditional woman moves a certain way
in when she's young
that's going to benefit her when she's
older a traditional woman is pure as a
virgin so but by that definition no you
can't become a traditional I think you'd
be traditional in practice like as in
not even one oh my God so wait you are
not indeed wow
if you look if you know if you look at
the body counts from before the 60s when
um birth control was introduced it was
like one two like the majority of women
only had one maybe two lifetime Partners
before the 60s that's mad okay so based
on another like they're like less than
five please
but so there's no way you can deem a
woman
um a traditional woman if she's had sex
I no no I wouldn't say that with her
husband
I'm just saying okay if we're talking
percentage rise right let's say you take
the average girl who she played the
field right and when she gets older she
wants a man that starts moving in a
traditional way right so you can be okay
she's like 60 of a traditional woman and
they take another woman who maybe she's
been like that since day dot okay she's
90 in terms of how traditional she is so
you can move in a traditional way I'm
just not like oh wait for me this way
that's that but there is to answer the
question what is a traditional woman
yeah I am confused I would say it's like
it's a woman that's pure she's youthful
um and if she's not youthful she's
married so like you can have a
traditional woman that's married if
she's older
um she has to like prioritize the family
above all else so I would say like she's
the type of girl that has like Kevin
Samuels would say do you have a cookbook
and it's true like what how do you how
do you Foster tradition in your in your
home but I I don't think you can be a
traditional woman unless you're either
married or a virgin I feel like being
traditional is boring like as women I
feel like we're constantly being told
how to be all the time like you have to
be like this
this is you're a feminist
are you a feminine yeah I guess so like
okay okay I'm not on anyone's side I'm
just lit I think I'm here today to just
learn right so do you now think because
being a what what is boring in being a
traditional
woman like the whole idea of like
staying at home and cooking and like
looking after the kids like
do you think you only think that way
because you're exposed to so much more
you know there's more that you can do
okay yes like that's why I said sorry so
can I ask the women here do you classify
yourself as a modern or a traditional
woman I think I couldn't trust between
both I think most everyone does both
yeah like I would love to be a
traditional woman but I don't have that
option because maybe I've made decisions
or I've gone through certain things in
life that now I may be deemed by the
likes of you guys I'm no longer
traditional I feel like you can go
through periods as well like when you're
younger you might be like
non-traditional and as you get older you
start to learn okay maybe there's some
value in being a business
decrease in value yeah like the whole
point is like girls want to sleep around
in their 20s and then at 30 run to a man
and like but you've lost the things you
that men value by the time you're 30
you're no longer pure you know you're
longer youthful and so men are kind of
tired of it because what happens is
they'll date the bad boys the rappers
whatever in their 20s and then they hit
30. one guy thinks like this is his
lucky ticket this girl's super into him
but she just wants kids and like she
really feels like she settles for him
she gets the kids and then half the time
leaves yeah can I ask a lady is a
question in the room do you want
a traditional man when I say traditional
man I mean the kind because if you're
going depends how far back you want to
go but we're talking like he tells you
it's his rules in his house
right so it's kind of like you utterly
submit to him right yeah he's paying the
bills he's protecting all of those
things but like there are pros of being
traditional yeah but there's the other
side of the coin that you have to accept
as well so I guess I'm asking do you
want do you guys want a traditional
money looking at me so if I'm if I'm
honest if I'm honest I think I could
have been with that when I was younger
so when I when I if my ex-husband if he
treated me like that he would have got
we would be living like that and it
would have been fine because we got
married young and everything and that's
all I knew but now that um I've had to
grind I've had to go through struggles
and stuff I've had to put myself in
certain situations it will it will take
a lot for me to decide to get into that
I think I'd want a mixture yeah like my
husband I think he is a mixture in terms
of obviously his his word is final but
he lets me do what I want to do there's
no restriction on that on on me so I
still think that's traditional okay I
don't think restriction is necessarily
like if your husband said
um like say say they wanted to go
somewhere and he said no I don't think
you should go would you say
um
I'd ask why
and if it was like if he said babe like
because he's he's in the security world
so he's one as when he says risk I sit
down
this is what I say sometimes when
because me and omatoya say we if I call
my testing and she's got a man I say
we're going out she says I'm not coming
I'll be like cool or even if she and
this is why it's when some people say
that um you shouldn't be friends who
with people who are single because
they're bad influence and I don't
believe that because you see my married
friends they can never call me to tell
me we're going to the club I'm not going
to snow club with you what are you doing
there yeah you're an exception though no
but there's a lot of girls that are like
most girls want their friends to be
single so they this is
why I always do anything wrong with
asking a single friend to go because
never take advice from women because a
girl will want to put you in the same
situation she's in how many girls will
get his friends will get a man and
they'll be like oh he's taking you away
from me
I agree with you I agree with you
because I I mean I think girls have fomo
like naturally like if if most girls if
you see all your friends are going to
something you're going to want to go and
if your dude doesn't want you to go like
I've seen
but in any relationship there's going to
be times where you're not yeah but I'm
sorry I keep interrupting sorry sorry no
but I'm saying so like in any
relationship there's going to be times
when you're not and I think sometimes
like when the rubber hits the road like
the single friends aren't the best
influence and I'm not saying all the
time but I'd say by and large you
wouldn't say most women are probably bad
influences on their on their married
friends I would never tell my friend to
leave her husband or do anything that
will impact her marriage if she's doing
something that's wrong I'm gonna tell it
it's regardless I'm single or not
because
I think as you get older and you get
exposed maybe because we're in the
podcast world and you have different
discussions you realize that look
everybody is here for their individual
things like we didn't come into this
world together and we're definitely not
going to leave together so you have to
respect if you love your friend that
much you will Embrace and make sure what
they've got going on is as successful as
possible if you mean that you're the
exception in it
I genuinely think you are an exception I
feel like I think you'll like that
though no no no no yeah when we when I'm
going through my issues and whatever is
to ride it out yeah I know but there's
some like that's like talking to you
one-on-one okay your personal situation
yeah I'm saying like for example as a
single person if my married friend was
having issues I'd like come out with me
like let's go do something like let's go
to the club to get your mind over things
but subconsciously it's it's not a good
influence yeah yeah so but you would be
the same person after after she's had
the fun you'll be the same person to sit
her down until Where She Went Wrong I've
seen you do it so many I think a big
part of it like I I agree I think I
think if a woman feels that the man that
she is with is the top man in the sub
she feels like she won with him right
then I think she's like you know what
now I don't feel like I need to I don't
feel like I'm missing out because I knew
how hard it was to find a man like him
but I think if a girl is or if a woman
is with a man that she feels like she
settled for then she can almost see the
opportunity of going out is still being
able to fish yeah do you have a reason
for going out then going out and was
fine
just go out just to enjoy yourself but I
feel women settle all this why why do
you think women will go to clubs do
women do women settle or do they get
what they can get like to me that's the
same dude yeah but I'm saying like I'm
not getting what I want you're getting
what I can get so it's a settle to me
right but I wouldn't say you're settling
if you okay if you go to the store and
you're worth five dollars and you're in
your Bot for five dollars you might you
might have like you know seen seen a ten
dollar product
imagine if you're going to go to UNI and
you're like oh this is no disrespect of
anyone here but it's like oh um I'm
going to reading uni now I'm setting him
for ready and I want to go to Oxford
it's like okay well did you get into
Oxford no well then you didn't settle
for the wedding that was the best choice
for you because we're all selfish by
Design and this is what happens when the
man that's a 10 bangs a girl that's a
three
then you call us deluded because we
think we can get a man that's a 10.
but it's because like women we're not
honest with each other like you you know
when your friend's sleeping out of her
League you know damn well but nobody
tells you you know what is that it's not
I don't think it's the sleeping with the
10 and whatever I feel like with with us
girls sometimes we get a little bit
carried away and we're not realistic you
may be sleeping with a guy who's a 10
but is he treating you like a 10.
treating you like a 10 and sleeping with
you like a 10 or three or whatever you
are is two different things how they
treat you is another is a whole nother
ball game yeah
I think women kind of like men that
don't treat them well though
I'm just I'm just saying like if if we
really hated toxic men why do we all
have a toxic ex because we're
traumatized
yeah but like but why would you date him
like I mean as a like as you're living
out your trauma basically you're okay
Until you realize that you're yeah
yeah
yeah
oh my God you just made it obvious it's
like
this guy gave me true more you picked
him no no I'm not talking about men see
I'm not even talking about men I'm
talking about like experiences in your
life like with your parents you know
like we are literally walking through
all my bombs wouldn't you say it's just
an excuse for poor decisions yeah no I
wouldn't okay what would you call it
I would say we're just walking trauma
bombs and we have to do the work to heal
ourselves so that we don't repeat the
patterns right the thing is I always say
to my friends look if you're in a toxic
relationship right and you and you
experience the same thing right another
guy comes along again toxic relationship
who's the common denominator in this
situation you so you're the problem so
fix yourself and then go get the thing
you want or maybe but maybe she's toxic
exactly yeah that's what I'm saying well
that's what I'm saying like a lot of
times girls will say oh like
like they blame it on the guys like oh
the guys are toxic and or they'll say
they'll say something like oh it's my
ability to pick but it's like
um is it your ability to pick or are you
toxic do you have toxic traits this is
what I'm saying yeah a lot of women are
toxic I don't think most girls even
saying that to their friends and this is
what I mean about don't take advice from
women because your girl will see a girl
will do something in a relationship well
there's always two sides to the story
and then she'll go to a girl and say
look he's doing this that in the third
you can throw in everything that she's
doing and another friend will say well
you know men are like this and blah blah
blah blah blah where does she take
accountability where does she have the
opportunity to heal and say let me
develop from this situation and make
better decisions in the future
your friends or your firm your behavior
I'm the exception no no but also like
you have to again you have to look at
your cycle right like if you're toxic
heavily toxic right the likelihood of
your best friend being toxic is quite
High how many people would admit the
genuinely toxic yeah I think I think it
starts from I don't know I I personally
think it starts from like having
children being a mother because I've got
a daughter and a son and whenever my
daughter comes to me and says oh Ezra
did this to me I said okay what did you
you do and then I find out she's done a
list of things and I have to hold her
accountable for it I don't because
sometimes especially being the girl you
get lit off with a lot of things 100 and
it starts from there I think younger
sisters yeah exactly yeah
Mom I don't know about that shots my
name straight away it's like I didn't
even
[Music]
not even in the house I feel like this
now this is a controversial thing but I
feel like moms love their sons more yeah
but you can say dads love their
daughters more so both are getting loved
yeah because it's quite I'm my mom's
favorite really I don't know why I think
it's I think it's quite common because
the whole thing of like so the whole
thing of okay it takes a father to raise
a man and takes a mother to raise a
woman right so when it and because
because men women we operate differently
right I will never understand what it
means to move in this world as a woman
you'll never understand we we play by
different rules so a lot of the time in
a lot of families the mother is the
disciplinary for the daughter and the
father is disciplinary for the for the
the sun it's like back in the day you
know be like the father would be like to
the son of King to go out there you need
to slay the snake or the rabbit and come
back and if he doesn't do it this the
father beats him but the mum's like come
here baby you did well like I'm proud of
you equally the mother to to the
daughter would be like okay you need to
fill these basket of berries right and
maybe she fills one basket not two the
father's like oh my little girl you got
a basket of berries but the mother's
like no this isn't good enough because
if you're going to be the wife of the
home you need to be able to do this so I
think often you know you say daddy's
little girl do you know what I mean
there's more mommy's boys than daddy's
little girls because a lot of people are
single parents yeah and there's no daddy
in the picture women raise men yeah no
they don't they don't they don't women
waste very Sims but a caveat to that
anyway wait say that again
I can like tell in a guy's voice if he
didn't have a mom in the home I don't
know how to describe it
I'm sorry
no no I'm serious like like you can just
tell in the way they interact with you
it's it's really we I don't know what
would you say it's like more feminine or
like slightly yeah or it's like they
almost like
it's almost okay I feel like when you
look at a kid that's a boy right it's
like they're they're naturally the
things men should be like they speak
their mind they like play they're like
rot like all that stuff and it's like
you see that 22 years later you can just
see they've been like feminized and it's
like they're almost like programmed to
think differently because like women
raise them or telling them what to say
and what to think
that's the same sorry could you say it's
the same with if uh the father was in
the life but it's not in the home do you
still see that
um it depends I think like if it's 50 50
custody potentially but if the mom like
I know a couple where like I can't tell
but they're usually older right you know
what I'm saying they're in a caveat to
that as well as that when it comes to
single-parent Homes single parent homes
with a father is the single parent the
kids tend to turn out better than when
the the mother is a single parent
do you know why that is I don't know why
that is
it's after the age of like women raise
better kids up to the age of like seven
where men raise better kids after and
it's because
um I mean they think it's because men
are more consistent where women are more
emotional so it's like confusing for a
kid like what's right what's wrong when
mom's on her period once a month and
like today like this is really wrong but
last week is kind of wrong you know
um and the other thing is that men are
better with money financially so yeah uh
no I mean majority the majority like
like women make 70 to 80 percent
consumer buying decisions we also spend
more even though we make less okay
and so like I own two phones
I'm gonna blame it on Sheen okay like
she needs to chill out
so I have a question for the women
how much does your submission cost
oh what do you mean like okay so when I
I use this example when I say submission
so he says babe trust me quit your job
no
do you think someone to spend the rest
of my life with okay and I've I've I
like gained that much trust for them I
think I would be able to do it 15 000
pounds a year is what he makes no okay
okay 20 000 pounds a year I don't think
it's even there's there's a that means
there is a prize there is a price for me
like
emotional security you know I really
need that moment
okay so emotional security but he earns
30k
women leave 70 to 80 of the time because
90 of their college educated like men
really don't leave because I mean we're
literally paid to leave
okay 50 000 pounds
sixty thousand pounds right so I can't
work at all like can I have a little
side Hustle No no no that's not the
point like you you I didn't tell you
what he's gonna have you do maybe you
work for him I don't know he just okay
he just says quit your job trust me okay
I think 55 000. I have a plan I think
fifty thousand fifty thousand yeah so if
it guys make it this is me
this is a lot of trust here she wants
that dead number four thousand fourteen
okay I'll take 50 off the tax as well
I'll say I'll say 50. I think I will
feel safe enough to like what what
percent of men do you think make fifty
thousand
like six percent no it's probably higher
it's not high but it's hiding there it
must be like 50. actually I don't I
would have thought it would be quite
fairly High I think the higher end in
the UK is seven years the average income
in the UK I think is between 24 and 28
000 a year that's the average so 40 of
Mary 10 make about 70k yeah and that's
the higher end so that's that would be
higher value in yeah so maybe it's like
15 percent
it says six percent of the UK population
earn more than fifty thousand dollars oh
my God
I mean it might be different in London
but it's a six percent of the UK
population earn more than 50 000 pounds
a year it only matter in London because
like five percent of that is in London
yeah yeah
right in this room I mean let me do let
me do so everyone go around say what
your submission costs I'm gonna
be honest as well
um
[Music]
he will need to earn
100 and something okay and and I know it
sounds like a wild number but the only
reason why I'm saying that is I'm
thinking about what I know costs are
right now
and I'm thinking if he could earn that
and even whatever he's got planned
doesn't necessarily go to plan I know
we're still okay
so yeah okay what do you think
um I think for me like you would have to
earn I don't know like probably like
over 100k like and I would have to get
money since my bank account like every
month like I would have to be getting
paid like I know you're asking a
question can I just ask her a question
so if he gave you 500 pounds a month 500
okay so I had this conversation with
someone right he's paying for everything
okay you have no bills okay you have no
nothing your phone bill every
electricity everything and he gives you
500 pounds to spend on whatever you want
every month is that enough how much is
he making that's not your business yes
no no I don't think a woman needs to
know how much amount is because we like
to spend their money for them before
they've made it so I don't think we need
to that's why she's smiling she's like
yeah yeah I'm gonna get that money
and your bills are paid like so what you
used to spend on by yourself or bills
used to you don't need to pay for that
anymore you've now got 500 pounds to do
your nails anything you want to do
500 pounds is that okay I mean if that's
all he can give that's all he chosen to
give he's not but we can he's just
chosen to give you 500. okay I have so
many questions but I mean like
it's black and white if that's the
minimum like sorry if that's like all he
can give then of course like I'm more
than happy to accept that because us
women with our words that's it's not
about whether it's all he can give he
has chosen to give you 500. all your
bills are paid it's not about chosen or
all he can afford it's not about what he
can afford he said you are getting 500
pounds
why don't you say that's nice of him
that is nice of him you're not happy
about it but like I want to know more
context about the situation
the whole thing of you whether you're
satisfied at 500 pounds
if that was all he could give it sounds
like he'd be okay yeah if he could give
you 5 000 it sounds like you'd be pissed
um
but you chose the 500.
I would like
the thing is as well like I would look
at my own circumstances well like how
much do I actually need you know like do
I need more than 500 because if I do
then I would have to have well you don't
need you don't in terms of everything is
painful everything's paid this is just
this is what would you need it for this
is your play money this is your plan
money this is Monopoly money lashes
Nails yeah I'd be fine with 500 of
course okay but why was it so hard for
you to because like
I don't know like for me I just feel
like if he's earning like a lot of money
and we're a partnership like we're
building
you know things together family together
a house together then why would he want
to limit me like I would like if if it
was the other way around I would always
give more I would always yeah I was just
about to say like why do you you part of
you guys building a house together and
whatever has not got anything to do with
you financially your part is keeping the
home safe and secure so so long if
that's our agreement between us then
yeah but as soon as so baby as soon as
you stop working and stuff
Financial was not part of your group you
you are yeah true I'm saying so why is
it I just feel like us women
like I'm I as well I'm trying to unlearn
a lot of bad habits of and I think it's
because we've been given so much power
in terms of the jobs that we have access
to so sometimes the jobs we have we
bring that mentality home and how we
communicate with men and all of that you
have to remember they're paying you so
they deal with our [ __ ] but a man
has chosen to marry you so I don't have
to deal with this even though I've asked
you to marry me I I decided to ask you I
didn't have to ask you the maddest thing
about that is that
you will go into work every day if even
though you hate your job and you won't
talk back to your boss yeah and in that
same scenario that we just painted where
your man's giving you free money Etc
you're still going to come back to your
man and try and cause trouble at home
that makes zero sense to me
in
that
session
my my
um one little thing that I would say is
that it's not the 500 that is an issue
for me it's
[Music]
um
the trust I feel like the trust should
go both ways so for me for me you
capping me at 500 is kind of like one
I'm a dependent you don't really trust
your children with money like that so
you're it's almost like I'm a dependent
I'm a child
um and secondly
for me as I said I feel like if you just
if your card's just there and just like
babe like do the shopping or whatever
you should trust me yeah as your wife
that I'm not going to be Reckless with
your money but it's for me I don't know
it maybe it's a me problem how it'll
make me feel yes not necessarily that
it's the cap that how it would make me
feel but also like you also don't you
also don't know why he's doing it yeah
like like saving for a house or
something but the whole point of
submission is like you trust him yeah
that's why Nations right yeah but that's
why I said it might be a real problem
that how how it makes me feel I see I
don't think it's a thing where like I
don't disagree with what you're saying
but I think we're all very like
intelligent adults yeah we just quoted a
stat that women own two-thirds of
consumer that you make all the I think
women are children actually
that's controversial
you're just trying to play the best
well you have to expand on that one no
no no if we know the facts as to how
women make consumer decisions then again
and you trust your man doesn't it just
doesn't it make sense that you know if
left your own devices over time you'll
become frivolous with that money yeah to
the situation I think it may be
different it may be subjective because I
handle all the bills and stuff in my
house not that I pay for it but my
husband I think I'm better with in terms
of your organization I don't know I
don't think I'm the exception I think
that might be a quality of a wife no I
think like a lot of girls are better at
like accounting yeah
you have like a whole spreadsheet you
know I mean we have the incomings and
I'm much more better with budgeting and
all that stuff yeah but I think men like
just don't make impulse decisions as
much yeah yeah like we'll see like a
cute outfit we'll be like buy it don't
even look at it yeah okay
um you um feeling that way about the 500
so if he had left you with his card
unlimited you probably will still spend
just that 500 anyway so is it not more I
might not I might not even spend the
thing exactly but that's foreign
it has like an underlying feeling of
like control so you might spend 100 I
might spend 50 years
not controlled well not for me well I
think I think like being feminine is
like giving up control is really hard
for most modern women yeah yeah like
because we're told to like we operate in
a masculine Society of like go out and
get it I disagree I think we operate in
a gynocentric society that puts women on
a pedestal and also bails them out of
every bad decision that we make ever and
tells us we're queens and perfect all
the time
when you say in a mask in society as in
in order to succeed in society yeah you
have to manifest and grow the things
that are traditionally masculine because
that's what's going to get the results
yeah
part of the issue is because this power
that we now have is new so we're now
learning things so for me if I had a
daughter and she was really successful
part of her her upbringing will also
know when to play that role when to take
power and when not to whereas back then
the parents didn't even the women didn't
have that power I don't think he said it
didn't know they didn't know to tell
their daughters or they we like I didn't
learn the things I know now from my mum
because my mum necessarily didn't become
the successful woman she was when I was
young as I got older so then when I
became successful and I realized I
understood what I really wanted and I
realized where the problem was coming
then I understood that you got a
different shape work and I think
is what does success look like to you
because to the traditional woman
successful success would look like
raising okay yeah it says to women now
looks like I want to make money as much
money success to me as a single woman is
being able to give myself the life I
would wanted if I was married
but that's because I'm single but
success to me as a married woman is
being in a home where my heart my
husband I can carry him literally on my
head and he is like my prize Jewel he's
successful I rub his back I support him
mad in her DMS
no but that's why I'm saying no but
that's why I'm saying to you that some
of us women the way we behave is is also
it's just our circumstances I don't
wanna I don't want to go to work
sorry but I'm saying like it's our
choices okay so yeah well okay yeah
you can't say any girl in this room
couldn't be married at 21 22. yes I got
married at 23 yeah yeah yeah
but what so without being an ass what
would you say to a woman who has okay
she's gone she's gone married she's gone
through those mistakes or whatever she's
come out of that marriage and everything
yes you know your children are important
blah blah blah but she wants to act
because I believe people make mistakes
and you should be given the opportunity
to correct them what would you then
advise that girl or that woman that has
accepted all her flaws that knows where
she's gone wrong and still wants to
potentially be in a home where she can
be submissive and everything is that not
possible anymore of course it's possible
oh okay yeah go on you go I mean I think
it's it's possible for sure I just think
like
you're not you're not going to get get
the same guys you could get at 22. 21
23. okay and you probably can't do
better than your baby daddy
I know you say that right and I don't
crochet that my ex or anything but I can
I think so but you know why I can not
because of not necessarily because of oh
I've got this money I'm Wiser yeah I I
understand life a lot more yeah but like
men don't care
um I think some do I think the caliber
of men that I unlocked
they don't care I don't disagree with
what you're saying I just think that the
type of man that you want you have to be
quite cognizant of the type of man that
you are like that you have to select
because I think women still have this
ideal that you're still going to get
this high value like Untouchable guy
about for most women when in reality the
type of man you have to accept isn't
going to be the type of man maybe he's
gonna have kids maybe he's going to have
yeah
because women operate on possibilities
not probabilities and there are
exceptions that could happen I mean I
would tell a girl get in the best shape
of your life so but I was gonna say I
think it's
I think that what we have to consider is
I get that like you've come out you're
in the right frame of mind to have
that's going to be conducive to the to
that life right and you've made those
mistakes whatever that's completely fair
I completely get that
the reality is it's not that you
couldn't get a man that maybe you feel
Worthy but the top guy right there are
other women out there who maybe had the
mindset you have now
before you made those mistakes okay okay
so those women who have that mindset
1921-22 right the mindset you have now
maybe they know those things because of
the way they've grown up whatever reason
they are just in a higher chance to get
that top guy
yeah how many women on the age of 20 to
25 would you say do you think have that
mindset now in the modern day times
do you honestly not many and that's why
not many Americans but that's why
um I don't know they say in like the red
pill that to date girls between like 25
to like 28 because it's kind of like
before they're running out of time and
they're desperate
I am not wow I mean I'm not but I I mean
I don't I don't know I don't know I'll
be honest I think I think the the the
women who have that are married
but who have that mindset if they have
the mindset of where their priority
because here's the thing if your
priority when you're younger right is to
have a family if that's your priority
most women who have that protein that
young they get married that young and
they have that now yeah yeah I think
what happens is and you know it's just
the way it is in the modern era
more women are choosing to prioritize
their career in their 20s well not only
that but
women who are bitter who didn't advise
younger girls to follow along the same
path as them so you'll get the single
mothers women that have been [ __ ] over
by men because of the wrong decisions
that they've made in topic as they go
for and then when they when they talk to
younger women they say oh you know live
your life just go out there sleep around
and when you get older you'll find the
right guy I've never gotten that advice
ever I listen so the way I have I no
because older older girls like lie to
you oh wow yeah but also like again
that's just like so toxic like you're
acting out of your trauma you know that
what do you mean acting out of your
trauma so most of us do that
okay
um but like acting out your trauma is
basically like okay so say you went
through something bad right like I don't
know you got with someone and you had a
kid with them and and they left you
right and then you then usually women
leave but yeah yeah okay cool in this
scenario the man left
um unless say
then that person then tells their
daughter just go out do what you want
blah blah don't get a man blah blah
right that's acting out of your trauma
because something bad happened to you
and because of that bad experience that
has now shaped your advice which doesn't
mean it's okay do you hear how you like
tell that story though it's like
something bad happened to you instead of
I made that decision like for some
reason with women whenever we tell
stories like it's we always take the
accountability off of us
hmm
you guys talk what is your submission
cost yeah
um
I would say
um
he can earn a little bit less than I
earn now because of like it will be less
responsibility on here less pressure
because this is going to be a two-person
household I feel like right now I earn
over 100k
and that's because it's just me by
myself I have to sustain it like like
two people so if he earned for like
let's say 80 or something and I'm
managing the household that's fine so
was the question not that we had to we
weren't working anymore right she never
she never specified
so the reason I use that question is
like you trust him enough that if he
said that yeah yeah so you won't be
working anymore yeah yeah but nobody in
the household but I have the pressure of
that like the point isn't that you would
like quit your job before the income the
point is like do you trust him enough to
make that decision oh even if maybe you
disagreed like maybe he wants to move to
the country and like go down in the
housing I don't know what he's saying I
always say something that I thought um
you see us women we talk especially when
we're single we always talk like
but once emissions come in a guy can be
your 15K and he tells us to leave
we could but this is the bad thing yeah
and that's that's just about to say that
these are part of the issues that we
have we don't think logically we always
think with our emotions is good
well I swear at the last show we talked
about leadership and I think someone
brought the fact that you know women can
be effective leaders and everybody's
like hard no I said I don't think I said
that um I don't know if I said did I say
on the live show that I said that um I
feel like the issue is women don't know
the power that they have don't know yeah
I said they don't know the power they
have they try to play the powers that
they think they need to have because
they see it glamorized so men in higher
positions and everything yeah and the
thing with us women is sometimes we're
very greedy we want a bit of everything
right so we see there being you see we
see men being glorified in that area we
too we want to go there
feminists we too want to go there and be
part of that party whereas we're being
glor we're being glorified here if we
were to embrace that position we don't
realize the power we have that's why
they always say behind every successful
man is a successful woman we don't
always need to be that's a feminist
probably you think Genghis Khan had a
successful woman but being being
successful doesn't mean having status
being being it was a successful woman a
good woman sorry but we don't have to we
can we we have an issue with not being
in the Limelight now so I can say that
back then yeah there's nothing wrong
with us being in the background Robin
he's back when no one's there and him
going out I don't know why women don't
get Thrills out of just knowing that I
think it's the lack of appreciation I
feel like someone said I don't know yeah
appreciation in terms of like when we
don't feel like okay babe thank you for
doing that or thank you being
appreciated for the little things after
a while we now want to fight to get
noticed it's just just to revolt that do
you do do we women say thank you for
going out to work that's fine thank you
for making the money thank you for
giving me the money to buy food 100 we
do not everybody
I think we're only learning
praise I'm in now I don't think men are
praised I think all of that is an
expectation good morning no more I think
all of them
and so it's like it's like we want a top
20 income 30 income but are you top 20
30 in women the reason why well I kind
of speak for myself the reason why I
want that right yeah because I I am that
yeah financially right but that's that's
what women do when they become the the
men that they want to marry yeah
you could say that I am that and I want
that and I understand but like for me
like I do pretty well this with this
show I would never in my right mind
expect a guy that I date to make as much
like it just wouldn't make sense but
like I said with me okay so imagine if I
was on like 300K and that guy was on
200k for me that's not a problem because
we can still live a certain quality of
life quality of life
you hit the nail on the head this is the
problem like this is the issue is that
women won't go down in lifestyle for a
family
and for peace and happiness because and
like they want to stay at that lifestyle
but it's like you know would you give up
getting your nails done getting like all
the things getting your nails done and
stuff isn't that's not the lifestyle a
smaller apartment a small like like less
of everything for a family for a family
and even you know quitting your job
letting him be the breadwinner for a
family
like Chris Rock made that joke you guys
men can't go back because sexually and
women can't go backwards in lifestyle so
like as women it's just like yo remember
when you're teen and you dated the first
guy you dated who had a car and he could
you could pick you up take you out
wherever when that when that ended
you're like yeah I don't [ __ ] with guys
you don't have a car anymore yeah yeah I
only [ __ ] good guys
that proves Maxi's point about 10
sleeping with threes what'd you mean
because when you've slept with a black
life but she wasn't a three though no I
think I was just saying about lifestyle
about what a man can do but this is why
I said girls adds to women's entitlement
because when you give them that
lifestyle the next guy they're expecting
that right they could have earned the
lifestyle oh yeah but you gave it to
them no no no I'm saying I'm saying like
like even themselves like could have
they could have the job and earn it
themselves like one of the things Kevin
Samuels used to say was like if like to
go down in lifestyle for the guy that
you want but like most girls don't want
to do that because the thing is I know
you're saying that we could or the girl
could earn the lifestyle but
honestly if it came to you free and you
had to work for it which one would you
take if it was given to you if your
lifestyle was exactly so they wouldn't
want to work for it if they don't have
it can I ask you something Maxie what's
wrong with a guy actually giving a girl
that's not as high level as he is
financial life financially yeah what's
wrong with the guy dating a three and
her thinking we weren't talking about a
three financially we're talking about in
her oh
he's probably just [ __ ] her that's
the difference
it does something to her mentality what
is wrong with her wanting something
better there's nothing wrong
okay okay uh okay this is we're gonna go
back to the cars
we have a used a Honda Civic with a lot
of miles and they they feel like they're
entitled to new BMW prices and they want
new BMW prices but when all the BMW
buyers are like nah that's a Honda Civic
I don't want a Honda Civic I want the
BMW they they they're like no offense
what's wrong with wanting what I want
you can want what you want but can you
get it
22 year old and then the Honda Civic is
at the 30 something plus but the the guy
that owned the BMW drove the Honda Civic
for like a week and now
and great addition to my analogy
yeah he was test driving yes
is this my new buyer and he's like oh no
yeah
I'm just
obviously are you trying to say what's
wrong with Aiming High is that what
you're trying to say like I just feel
like if okay for me if you're saying
three it's a whole package I think that
means she's not worth that much right
well I think what Pearl is trying to say
if threat me if I'm wrong is you're
fishing way out of your league
it's what men value so like if if men
value Purity Youth and you don't have
Purity and youth and you want to top 20
guy in terms of income like I just think
it'd be hard there's exceptions but but
I'm not feeling entitled it's just
yeah I think I think what I was gonna
say is I think the mistake a lot of
women can make is they think their
league is the guys who have sex with
them and their league is actually the
guys who will commit to them literally
because men are judged with a caliber
woman they can get whilst women are
judged by the caliber man they can keep
very true if you can't keep demanding
you have no value in that situation
right but do you see how that confuses a
woman though not really because if
you're if you're smart and not it's not
smart but if you're just and this is why
I always talk about self-awareness and a
lot of us lack self-awareness if we were
truly self-aware and cognizant of our
behaviors you can understand that okay
here's this guy who I'm attracted to but
based on these behaviors he's not trying
to do anything to keep me yeah we'd
never ever take things at face value
well you don't know women and this is
what I mean by women who actively know
ignore reflex because you know when you
look in hindsight this guy wasn't doing
[ __ ] like he literally slipped in your
DMs said when I'm coming to your yard
and you're like yes
is this from experience
you better make that blink Shimmer boy
well I think you're right it is
confusing it is confusing to the woman
who doesn't understand men
and I think a lot of women don't and a
lot of women don't and I think a big a
big reason of that which is part of the
reason why this show is as big as it is
is because whenever men in recent 10 to
20 years have expressed okay this is
what I like this is what I look for this
is what I commit to a lot of the time it
is shamed as misogyny and patriarchal
etc etc so then what happened was men
like we're not going to say anything
we'll just show by our actions but I
think what can happen is like you said
like especially for girls having sex
with a guy and she really likes him she
gets clouded yeah so she doesn't see oh
actually no all the men who all the
women who actually get in commitment
they're moving in this way and the women
who aren't getting commitment like
myself they're doing the same thing I'm
doing and it's hard to see that I
understand that but if it comes to the
man's fault and that's and that's the
problem because yeah it's not your fault
it's the woman will say well you didn't
treat me right when in reality it was
never right in the first place
people treat you how you allow them to
treat you yeah but why must the man
treat wrong like why am I
okay this is what girls say when they're
shooting out of their league like like
they'll say oh why isn't he treating me
right now he's just not giving you the
attention you want because you're not on
this level but when he can get any girl
he wants it's easier easy
it's like okay okay let's go back to the
cars
if a guy wants a free test drive on a
car that he has no intention of buying
is he going to go to the salesmen that
are you know selling these really nice
cars when they can kind of see that he's
not looking for anything or is he gonna
go to the Honda Civic dealership he's
hungry to make yourself yeah because
he's a 10 he could probably still get
the girl that's a 10. that's the point
though but why can't he go to the Honda
Civic guy and say oh I want to test
drive but Dave is basically I'm not
basically buying this car because
yeah because then he would he wouldn't
get the test drive yeah
yeah because if a guy because if a guy's
like come to you just like hey look like
you look nice yeah I just want to have
fun with you today
you've got nice cheeks and I want to
spread them tonight but that's all I
want oh cheese but I would say what I
would say is this a man tells you what
he wants to his actions
I think women
would be in a better position ah thanks
and I think for me it's the opposite I
think men need to listen more look less
because some guys get some guys would
tolerate nonsense because she's so far
you know and he's like yeah I don't
think that's even the main focus of men
because you have to remember when you
look at it holistically only 20 to 30
percent of men are actively having sex
so really for for true happiness to be
sought is there's that there's been
there's been this death of the average
so average women don't want average men
that's true and those would work all
together so if only 20 to 30 of men are
having sex what does that mean it means
that most women are sleeping with the
same men yeah but if you ask a woman do
you want to share the high value men
that you've got they will say no but
then what makes really different from
any every other pretty girl that there
is out there because once you hit once
you become a 10 guy every woman on the
market becomes available to you so what
makes you any more special than another
woman so please advisor what would you
then um advice women to do then so they
should just settle within their means
um well I would say okay okay I I have I
don't know what do you say oh you can't
do you wanna you can you can start I
want to start this is what I do I have I
have a couple options so first of all we
need to understand what settling is
because a lot of women seem to think
settling is a problem so can I explain
to you what I think in in my life
settling is
um for me settling
you see for me quality of life is very
important and peace is very important
amen and what leads to my peace is my
home me being so happy to be there yeah
so if I don't feel happy to be there
because the quality of my life is not on
a certain standards then I'm not at
peace so this is what I would say right
the first thing I would say is what are
your three non-negotiables and you're
only allowed three and you everything
builds from there so you say the things
that are important to you right
you get food you get digestive but the
things that are important to you right
you get three non-negotiables in the man
that you're gonna choose I know what
you're gonna do no but I'm just asking I
already know what he's going to do wait
what do you think what I'm going to do
because I'm going to say I mention three
things right and when I mention them and
you say but what if you can get that in
a guy that owns 15K no no no no no no no
that's what I'm saying what I was going
to say what I was going to say is this
right if you have three non-negotiables
yeah and and you build everything
outside of that you have to be flexible
in you're asking okay a woman who's gone
through this process she's made mistakes
she's here she's got this frame of mind
now what does she do this is what she
does you have three non-negotiables and
everything outside because most women
they have a list of 10 15 20 things
maybe when
I just keep it a buck right maybe when
you're younger and you have every guy at
your disposal you can afford to be that
picky
but when you get older you've had to
experience the way the market is you
can't afford to be that picky for most
women most women can't yeah but that
doesn't mean you shouldn't be able to
get a chance I'm just I'm I'm just as
we're just picking each other's brains
so like as you're saying now that okay
you know in Taiwan
some there's some guys that do approach
you and
you're not attracted to them okay so
this is this is the second thing you're
not feeling forget even the looks that
they don't yeah okay so this is this is
the second thing right
do you always wait for a guy to approach
you
I don't have them no no hold on hold on
hold on
I'm just asking like if you are only
going to choose from The Men Who come to
you and that's okay but then you can't
then complain about the lack of options
how can you how can you get what you
want if you don't go after okay but in
the form I'm I'm asking in the form of
trying to be submissive is it ladylike
to even approach there is a feminine way
right tell us the feminine way because I
would love to know the men communicate
differently men communicate overtly
whilst women communicate covertly part
of what women do is they they
signals you know back in the day they
used to be like they used to drop their
handkerchiefs
also also I'm just giving you a quick
plug
um we're starting wife uh a channel
called wife school where we bring in
some wives to teach modern women in 304s
to be wives
I always see three or fours or 304s
if you feel like you've been in the
streets too long I can't do this
I'm a modern woman I don't know what to
do and you're like all these red pill
channels they never come up with
Solutions but here here we're solution
minded we're gonna bring it we're going
to bring in wives to teach you how to
cook wives to teach you how to wash it
what follow my channel I'll give you
Solutions that's what I do
that's what my channel I can't you're
gonna be featured on wife school I'll be
there he's going to teach women how to
how to you're going to teach women how
to approach stop it we're gonna we're
gonna teach you're gonna teach women how
to approach approach men right very true
okay
I would love a little lesson now okay so
situation this is not a situation you're
a ball you're with your girlfriends you
see God you like first of you've been
with your girlfriends right 99 of men
are not approaching you because to him
you just like a pack of wolves okay it's
not happening so the first thing you
have to do is you have to separate
yourself from the group
okay right and there's a point that you
separate yourself from the group now
while you're in the group right you see
the guy you like it's very important you
make eye contact now here's the thing
when you're out and about everyone makes
eye contact right you might look guys
once or twice right but you need to
maintain that eye contact right so you
see him he sees you right the next thing
you do right if you do that and he
acknowledges you that's cool next time
you do it you give a smile
it's quite right
because because all it is about right
because thing is if you're not
attractive women if you're an attractive
woman 80 of guys want to approach you in
that club but the truth is 79 feel they
don't have the permission to so by you
doing this is giving him the permission
to approach you once you've done and
you've sent these signals you have to
separate yourself from the group okay so
maybe like oh to be right girls go to
toilet all the time so maybe not a
toilet but maybe you're like okay I'm
gonna go get a drink at this side of the
bar where I'm by myself and you give him
the opportunity now here's the thing if
it's a man who is with his world with
all he's got a level of emotional
intelligence right and he finds you
attractive and he's there's a level of
confidence which I assume is the kind of
man you want he's going to take that
chance
and if he doesn't let's say he doesn't
right and you're like I didn't take a
chance but have you come back
if you see him up at the bar right and
I've said this to my clients and this is
what several times
all you say is hey can you help me try
and get Adrian I've been trying to get a
drink for ages and they've not been seen
to me and if what if there's like no one
in the bar you're a [ __ ] ball if there's
no one at the bar well then you know
he's that's definitely the signal there
because all you're doing is you're just
opening a door and nine times out of ten
right nine times out of ten a guy's
gonna go because a guy wants to feel
like the man to go don't worry man let
me get us a drink right and then you
start a conversation and that is that is
literally half the battle of meeting
that I'm coming to you with your friends
my husband would have approached me with
the friends and taken me away that's
cool but most but like no no you're a
one percent man if you can do that
because most of the code approaches is
the is dying men haven't they don't
practice the skill of the cold approach
anymore of course I grew up doing that
stuff so uh
you grew up yeah 100.
I'll be honest I used to do that and
rejection is what I used to call it
because after them days you just had to
Grand we used to do a numbers game me
and my boy would go to a certain
locations Let's see we get 10 numbers
wow Freedom at reply you might be able
to top one
me and my boy used to the same thing but
the reason I didn't do that now and I
don't advocate for men to do that now
because ain't no one looking for a
sexual harassment charge no no no no no
but the thing is and the reason I say is
important whilst you're younger is
because you learn how to communicate
with people effectively at that age yeah
so at the time that's when you learned
to pick up social cues because women
will signal yeah where most men fails
they're not attuned to those signals
with the look like I said with the
separation of the friends just smile
most guys will still see all those
signals and stuff like that like yeah
I'd only get turned down that's true but
for me that's that's a heightened
approach if you give me all those
signals it's long yeah but that's how my
sponges game over I hear that but like
most but like I said that's one percent
most guys aren't going to do that that's
true and I've noticed that as well like
when I was younger a lot of guys would
like come up well
bigger myself out but you know like guys
generally
so much more confidence whereas nowadays
I just feel like they never approach you
in this do you think that you can go to
a guy yeah I've all like not always but
yeah there's been a lot of times where I
have approached a guy to be fair I have
been drunk right
um it is harder like when you're sober I
don't know like I don't have as much
confidence but yeah like I like that
what do you say
oh
okay this is a bit strong and bear in
mind I was drunk right but in one
scenario I said are you gonna get me a
drink okay that's all right but I say in
like a feminine way I smart you I mean
like there's like body language to this
as well
because it might come up with that one
yeah
at your drink only when we're having
great interactions because a lot of guys
where they go wrong is that that's their
that's their
approaching and to me that's Sleazy and
it shows you've got no decorum now girls
will finesse you for that though exactly
a drink mate do you know how come on you
guys have had it like how many girls go
out they're like they don't even spend a
penny but they get wasted oh yeah that's
something that's gonna come out of their
persons
she come back to me with free drinks wow
I I'll be there I'll be honest maybe I
shouldn't admit this I'll be honest I've
been out with a girl that I was dating
right and she was standing she gets hit
on all the time by guys I know and like
she'll be like let me go get some drinks
and she'll just go get a guy to buy a
couple drinks she'll be like oh can you
buy a drink for me and my friend not
knowing it's for me
I'll be like listen if you're a team you
use what each other has got but hey it's
true Did you know that they're
predicting that 50 of women
um in childbearing years so basically
between the ages of like 25 and 45 will
be single and childless so much so that
there's big companies investing in
things like wine cat food wow I've
invested in egg freezing because that's
going to become more yeah
that's really good idea what does that
say about the state of modern women
today
[Music]
um
um
it's kind of sad really it's sad but
never mind
speak your mind Cambridge is actually I
think I'll listen to LBC and Cambridge
designed to do courses on fertility for
women because they believe that girls
aren't taught young enough about their
bodies so they Chase your career chase
this and Chase that but they're not
taught okay you actually have a
biological clock so they're actually
looking to teach skills in in secondary
school okay you know by this age this is
the amount of eggs that disappear etc
etc yeah so again it it's telling of the
society because
people think people argue about
conspiracy theories about you know
overpopulation and stuff like that but
in the US
um in most countries in Europe people
actually dine out in Japan they have a
negative
um population yeah and most of them yeah
like it's just like most people
congregate in major cities so that's why
we believe the overpopulation nonsense
but it's really not a thing yeah 20 of
cities hold 80 of the population yeah
wow I think you need to have 2.5 babies
per person Society or culture to
maintain a culture yeah but in Italy
it's like one point something in Spain
it's one point something so did she die
now overpopulation is good I was an
economics major really good for an
economy because it's like cheap labor
yeah China's a perfect example yeah but
even in a place like Singapore they
promote sex so they have like parks and
stuff which is made to make people feel
like they want to have sex yeah
they're promoting sex but they're
promoting marriage because
traditionally the argument to get
married first and then I don't know
you're right but
I just think with birth control like
women don't really want to be wives
anymore
in general a woman feel like they can be
more like men
true but I think there's like they get
access to guys they would never get
access to in the past and anything below
that they feel like they're settling so
I think a lot of women will take side
chick over being a wife I agree and
because yeah I agree do you think they
should stop providing free birth control
I was literally going to ask that
question
families would come back together I
understand why you say that in a sense
you think if people were not on connect
decisions a lot more wisely because now
you've got something that you could just
do whatever you want but you've got
protection you're kind of backed up yeah
yeah so I get that but what you know you
always think about people that get great
yeah
people that get grapes and stuff and all
of that kind of stuff and essays and all
of that kind of stuff so do you
do you not think instead of not having
access to it do you not think there
should be maybe a stricter process a
condition no I would banish it all okay
it would be like 100 banished in Pearl's
World
why do you want to protect the essays
I don't think you make loss based on
less than one percent of pregnancies
like I just I think you make laws based
on the rule not the exception so
um the reason that I would say I just
think that everything like if you look
at the divorce rate in society it's
literally pinpointed by the same rate
that women were on birth control so like
as more women got on birth control the
more women were like having sex getting
divorced okay yeah I mean probably and
the other like misconception is a lot of
people think like abortions would go
through the roof or whatever if there
was
um no birth control but actually
abortions increased after birth control
didn't decrease and 40 of women that
have had an abortion about two or more
so it's like okay I think that makes
sense because people don't take
accountability well I just think there's
no consequence and so like birth takes
away the consequences for women I mean
how much more careful would women be
with who they slept with if they weren't
on birth control I have a question for
the girls though do you think you'd be
in happy relationships
um when you've had like more sexual
experiences no no I don't think sex has
anything to do with a good relationship
for us women
wait I say the question again
different like sexual experiences or you
had more yeah
are two different things like sex can
just be sex and a relationship is more
long-term like there's commitment you
know why I ask that question is because
most girls would want to sleep with
multiple partners is because some men
are just [ __ ] in bed
how would you know if you're a virgin
and that's that that's why but you can
always work on sex yeah you can always
like communicate you know you can look
stuff up on the internet
if you don't know what good sex is yeah
what makes it sorry is good sex not what
makes you feel good if you're liking how
you're feeling then you're gonna deem it
as good sex regardless if so it's not
passive yeah I think what everyone deems
as good sex is some people say that oh
when you have sex with the first but
someone the first time it's not
necessarily great but as you get to know
each other's body it becomes better so
then I don't think you need to be
exposed so much you just have to
understand each other and have that
connection so don't you think it's
better to do that with one person and
then have multiple experiences then yeah
yeah 100 yeah yeah I don't think you
need to sleep with many people no
definitely not and in terms of like a
sexual connection as well like you could
have sex with someone who's amazing in
bed
um and maybe it's not treating you as
good as someone else or that you have a
stronger chemistry with and he's not as
good in bed but I think as a woman
you're emotionally connect with a person
who's not as good yeah you want to go
out of the Good Wood
is it the same for men or no like do men
um if men slept with left less women
would they be oh is that yeah
statistically um so the the best
outcomes is when they're both virgins
okay so that's that's one thing I think
sometimes like people gloss over however
um a man that slept with around eight or
nine if I remember correctly
um Partners versus three is happier in
his marriage okay so actually men's
happiness goes up at some point rather
than down when they've slept with more
people and I think it kind of goes back
to like like a lot of things
like I guess red pill trees are kind of
known in society like before but they
would say men would go sew their Wild
Oats and then go get a wife
but yeah the more people a woman slept
with the kids I have a question for the
panel how many times have you fallen in
love
once once once once
I don't know if I have you know I don't
think I have evil um
I'm falling in love before
um
I feel like I've experienced different
types of Love though you see you haven't
fallen in love no I have you have okay
yeah but
there's one time two times oh I was 16
and she was like 20.
she was my substitute teacher
literally my age in life I think it's
infatuation yeah
today she might still be able to get me
make sure she looked the same I don't
know
the idea of uh you find enough of the
idea
the way I envisioned her like she was my
queen
the first time I got drunken [ __ ] they
say that man like it's kind of weird
like every girl that they've been in
love with they kind of like love them
forever in like a weird way that women
won't understand because we only love
one guy at a time that's right say that
again it's like I've heard this I'm I'm
butchering it but basically like men can
love multiple women at the same time and
so like there'll be a lot of times it's
a common story like oh he's still in
love with his high school girlfriend or
High School something and like it's an
archetype that I've just heard over and
over again and it's like
men when they fall in love with someone
it's like they're in love with them
forever and like women won't understand
that but then what about the idea that a
woman who's had multiple partners is
still loving her ex well that's that's
because that was the best she could do
so like I mean historically women ended
up with the best guy they could be with
because otherwise their husband would
get killed and she'd get taken by the
best guy I mean that's why women this is
an uncomfortable this is an
uncomfortable truth but the number one
requested
um like
Rico he had a male only fans model on
the show and the number one thing women
request is grape that's great wow yeah
that's crazy yeah and I and like like
why do women like being like choked why
do women like yo it's because like
biologically they they kind of ah I
don't know if I should say okay
why do girls like the handmaid's tale
when women love that show
my adult
experience the woman who has been the
most dominant and successful Mexican at
work is the one who wants to be utterly
dominated at home
um yeah okay so I think um like that I
like I like to feel like someone else is
in control yeah right but it's because I
feel like in my whole life I've had to
be in charge and I don't like it so I'd
like to come home and know that I can
put all my goodness chalky no
oh you talking about sexually I was
talking about sexually oh because well
because that's what you were saying
right you said about early months for
modeling that yeah yeah it's like like
so so I was saying like women want to be
with the best the guy they could
historically because we we would be but
now it's it's not like that and so like
if a girl experiences experience as a
guy that's like too high like she'll
think about him forever and you and you
all know you have a friend that always
runs back to that same EX
I think that's why that's why they got
like we were talking about twin flames
before you know you know the thing about
like the love and being a love thing and
always have enough for that person I
think that goes for men and women they
you know they're saying they say the
first love Cuts deep and I I or the
first love is very deep and I think for
men and women because like we've been
having this conversation the other day
that the first guy that goes with right
that she basically has her everything
like the sex with him and emotional or
whatever right
almost a lot of guys after that are
almost a different like an archetype of
that guy because it's like the first
love is almost like an imprint it's like
it's like the first
I've heard this song guy had a theory on
this and I'm curious if the girls think
this is true so first first three guys
that a girl sleeps with the best out of
the three that's her type forever
I think your type changes over time as
you evolve over time right like you
learn more about yourself what you like
what you don't like would you would you
say um the older you've gotten like how
has your type changed you go for like
the bad boys you know like the guys that
used to treat me like [ __ ] and then as I
got older I was like oh they treat me
like [ __ ] so like my change has
completely changed like I go for
different looks complete I go from more
personality you know like what do you
mean for like the the sexual part like
comparatively between the good guy and
the bad guy as your as your preference
in bed change as well
okay yeah but I feel like don't you feel
like you can only get y Zone all of this
stuff by experience so did you have to
date different type of guys to know what
you don't want 100 yeah yeah
that's but see this is like the common
complaint of man is that women give
their best years to guys that are bad
and then expect them to pick up the
pieces after when people say that
um
I think my best year well forget about
the your beliefs of Virgin and all of
that but as always
yeah when I think of my traits and my
personality and how I man carrying
myself and everything I'm a better woman
now yeah yeah but yeah okay so yes to
yourself if you're basing it if you're
basing it on
um me being a single mom and all of that
stuff then yes no matter what I do I may
not but if someone was to take the
chance to get to know me now and got to
know me a man get to know me back then
he would prefer the woman he would be
more willing to get to listen to hear me
out now than he would back then and
that's even when I was with no kids
single and whatever and you you might be
like a more agreeable woman now would
you say that's true I'm a what agreeable
like a real ball kind of goes with
femininity like maybe you're more
feminine now oh 100 yeah and so like
that might be true but like what gets
you in the door is like looks Youth and
kids are no kids because because it's
like like a guy has a checklist of
things here yeah 100 and so it's like
you're not in the same doors no well I
would like I think I think there's
qualities that attract a man and there's
qualities that people man yeah I know
correct me if I'm wrong I think you're
saying the qualities that you have that
will keep in mind now is superior than
what you had before yeah but I think
what almost they're saying is that maybe
the qualities to attract the man maybe
it's a little bit lower than it was
before but I do think that a man will
compromise on the attractive qualities
for the right I mean I don't say like
all hope like my my sister was a single
mother and she got married too I would
say she did better than her baby daddy
but like I I think it was an exception
it's not the rule why would you I would
add that men are probably more likely to
tolerate bad characteristics
for women to have less baggage because
it's like if I had to if I had to look
at it comparatively would I take a woman
with a child over a woman that was more
problematic problematic but no child I
probably go for the one that's more
problematic just because
at least I can make the mistakes with
her instead of having to carry on
someone else's baggage do you feel like
you can the the quote unquote things
that you don't like you know you feel
like that's more malleable whereas like
you're saying like the child like the
child's there like that's it yeah yeah
because that's something irreversible
that I can't change would you say the
same thing
as in what would I take more problematic
with no child I'll be honest if I was
looking to like say I don't have kids
now I would
have a chance
I would take I would take the more
problematic if I feel that we could work
together but I feel like a lot of men
surprise themselves like I feel like
sometimes as well like you don't know
what you would do until you're in that
situation that's even us I'll put my
I'll put my hands up right I've dated
single mothers before and
Daydream abandoned in single girls oh
singing robbers are lit they [ __ ]
know
what's the difference
especially if they have sons yeah
because well they take care of the
taking care of the nurturing the yeah
you're so submissive yeah
they know they have less leverage
for that reason because I know
intrinsically that the only reason
you're that way is because of the
mistakes you've made okay so what's
wrong with that I don't want that why I
don't want it but why well I I pick
why would that picture
analogy is coming again
all the qualities you want in a woman
she has it but just because she has
experience or a child that's not a small
thing and a child you're saying you
won't maybe her no way but you date her
I'm a Nigerian man as well you're a
Nigerian no you're not damn I thought
you were okay it was a bumper Club yeah
I think I think what this highlights is
that
how women see a woman with a child and
how men look at it is completely
different like where we're so easy with
being with getting with a guy that has a
child
the expenses don't fall on us yeah true
so I was going to say that about how
women could maybe not initially I don't
think they would aim to go for a guy
with a child but I think if they fell in
love and got to know a guy
yeah
it's in our pockets yeah well it's an
attraction trigger for women so like men
are biologically predispositioned to be
repulsed by other people's kids that's
why they have this reaction to it wow
yeah because historically what would
they do they'd take the women and kill
the kids
like if one it would be tribes so if one
tribe conquered the other tribe it goes
back to what I was saying earlier like
where women would end up with the best
male yes so if one tribe conquered the
other tribe they would take the fertile
women okay they would take the the they
might they might take a girls if she's
old enough but they kill the kids
and a big reason of that they had to
yeah it's not it's not good it's just
not yeah I think it's a big reason that
comes back to what you said is as a man
if you're going to choose a woman who
has kids then the responsibility of the
child often falls on you and the truth
is like I said we're selfish by Design
right the reason that we kill the kids
back in the day was because as a man he
it was his job to put his life on the
line for the family and best believe if
he spent his life online for his family
he's doing it for his own kin and not
someone else and women like men with
kids because historically if he had a
kid that was a sign of pre-selection he
could take care of other women yeah it's
a sign of responsibility actually also
another fun fact is
um felons have 30 more kids than
non-felons so when women say they're
like nice guys cap
[Laughter]
um okay I'm gonna take a second and read
the super chats okay guys
um also big up to blessing who is now
officially shooting in 4k that's the
whole day setting this up so
um shout out blessing you wanna you
wanna say anything blessing
um he also we also want to use the Super
Chat money to get a camera
um that is that shoots in 4k we're about
three thousand dollars short 8K oh yeah
8K sorry not with that 4K
um yeah the camera is it's really
expensive but we've raised a lot of the
money but we're about 3K short so send
donations that is what we are trying to
get
um next uh Christopher cerdak
a single mother or divorced mother is
damaged goods periods there is no
argument here for men mgtow by Logic
marry a man ASAP your value to a man is
plummeting by the minute I'm a 40 year
old millionaire and I wouldn't date any
of you mgtow by Logic a husband is a not
a car you select men are human beings
you can't just wait till you're old and
bitter and then demand a top deer to
your man it's lunacy mgta by Logic yes
you used to like a bad boy now you want
a good guy just like every just like
nearly every woman ever LOL wake up the
ignorance is annoying
um every woman on this panel is an alpha
Widow obviously an ignorant of the fact
Dylan um for the dude in the back in the
Naruto shirt Eugene I do not consider
myself a passport bro but I would not
mind getting a passport to fly to
England to try to get with one of these
ladies Russell um remember this the
spectrum of viewers haters are gonna
hate
um The Savvy ninja legit ratings for the
show from left to right guys including
included ratings equals looks energy and
potential ladies 5.5 5.7
6.36.36.8 man equals 6.7 6.5 flavor
County Country
this is why Kevin Samuels talked about
smiling about smiling the ma about SM
this is why Kevin Samuels talked about
smiling the smiling at the man you want
you open up him up to you and you should
do this two times one for eye contact
and the second time to give the okay to
come over marriage causes divorce women
should never settle it'll only cause
cause Divorce mgtow by Logic hypergamy
requires that men settle not women men
are the ones settling not women
Christopher surdak sorry ladies but if
you're not getting flowed out to Dubai
to get peed on you're not a 10 probably
not even an eight or a nine Mr T-1000
it's only two types of women wives and
everything else the UK Economist please
ask your guests if they would accept
their high value man keeping their kids
from another man that's not wait please
ask your guests guests if they would
accept their high value man keeping
their kids from on from another man
that's that's not out of his inheritance
Mr T100 a hundred dollar dinner date
equals one home-cooked meal or lunch in
my book life is about Equivalent
Exchange how much does it cost to make a
brother a peanut butter and jelly
um a little goes a long way funny the
guy said single moms give bad advice
like sleeping around it's like they want
women to end up in the same position as
them 93 Tope women are dumb for
hypotheticals not all but most
Christopher these girls are discussing
marriage but describing prostitution
they're all for the streets Russell
Wallace Warren I appreciate the
discussion thanks Champs 93 Tope women
are dumb for hypotheticals not all but
most
um Damien
it's the if it's the consumer in her she
wants to be able to spend every cent
he's earned with no thought about saving
and investing marriage causes divorce
green jumper chasing the man's bag big
red flag Kanye
um oh no the three witches are back
marriage causes divorce
um women won't submit unless he's a Chad
that's rich
um dubman Pearl there's another Pearl
the reason mothers are more important
for their Pearl the reason mothers are
more important for kids up to the age of
eight is that they need nurturing more
at that age dad is more important from 9
to 18 because they need structure more
than nurturing 90 free Tope the movie
Joker is why single moms are bad for
boys 90 free Tope
as long as women have a way out they
will never choose to understand context
It's All About Me me feels feels feels
it's not all Chaska 2.0 and white
um Eugene steel a real A real friend
would respect his friend in a
relationship she would not try to
interfere with the relationship
um V Jokers men in their mid-20s and 30s
and mid 50s have had enough of modern
ladies game
facts enjoy being alone ladies Damien
when it comes to men we want boring and
predictable when it comes to a wife this
notion of being unpredictable and not
sure of what you want is fun for a side
piece but not for a wife mgtow by Logic
I guarantee you won't be thrilled for
working for 50 years but you won't find
a husband at 35 you'll be invisible I
promise
um danik Anthony to get a modern woman
traditional all you need to do is
unscramble the egg and put it back in
the Shell mgtow by Logic women
misinterpret the time they have to have
kids you don't have from 17 you don't
have 17 years from 18 to 35 you have 204
instances of egg drops between 18 and 35
that's six percent of your fertility
burned each year whether you use it or
Not mgtel by Logic a lot of women yeah
well a lot of women start off not
wanting kids or later than try until
after the age of 25 and then when they
find out they can't marriage causes
divorce modern women equal city girls
single moms boss babes Matt butcher what
is up with the late start this is
getting really old Florida rest easy
thousands of women are on standby ready
to restore your power after the
hurricane
um okay that was all Let me refresh it
real quick guys like the video make sure
you like it that is the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these lives so if you like the content
you think that the message is important
to spread make sure you like the video
um Russell Wallace Warren first drafts
are terrible Ernest Hemingway Lawrence
Bullock how is it that drug dealers and
gang members have problems getting women
but the average have no problems getting
women but the average man college
student
the average man college student
struggles to get a date
Henry Lucy hey Pro loved the show I can
afford the 500 pound bills every month I
live in one of London's safe Financial
districts tell the ladies to audition
for submission but they need to accept
accept that I will step out from time to
time The Savvy Ninjas the ratings for
the ladies tonight each got point five
to one point up because because as black
women especially their weight is under
control Christopher surdock a mother a
single mother a single mother or diverse
mother is damaged goods period there's
no argument for men mgtow by Logic okay
I read them all what do you guys think
oh yeah
the black women will always now the wait
comment was a bit that's nice
today was good yeah
the three witches are back here
102 Badcock that today was fantastic
um what do you guys think would you if a
guy had all the things you were looking
for would you accept him stepping out
from time to time I thought about this
before
um yes no I'm not hang on let me answer
the question
um we have this notion that Menchie
right and so the thing is like if you've
already built and spent so many years
and you've invested so much of your life
with this person and they've stepped out
and if you generally believe that
Menchie if you leave to go to find
another Mountain then aren't you just
gonna end up repeating the circle again
anyway so are you not are you not better
off just staying in the position and
working it through but I don't condone
it and I do not respect it you have to
understand that my behavior towards you
may change slightly as a result yeah I'd
like to always remain naive to the fact
that he's cheating I think if he brings
it to my doorstep I think it's more
about the disrespect more than anything
I think men cheat I think women women
take back men that don't tick all their
boxes so
to me is it not that I'm condoning
because I don't yeah and I don't accept
it but if I'm going to take back
somebody who doesn't tickle my boxes
then I'm gonna take back somebody who
does yeah
I think if we have like is it monogamous
where it's just like you're monogamous
to him but he
okay yeah every now and then no no no I
have to stay like that so that's why I'm
saying like if it's a monogamous he'll
stop
maybe if we've agreed to not do that and
he then did that yeah then we would I
don't know I feel like
at that stage you either have to decide
whether you want to work for it you
really love context sorry sorry
um if you agreed so you think you're
going to sit down with your man and
you're going to say well we're not going
to cheat and it's going to be a yes dear
I think it's like a continual
conversation
I think like especially nowadays like if
you're 20. if you're 20 years in yeah
you're gonna keep telling him I hope you
know we don't cheat here
it's a conversation like has your mind
changed yeah we still do exactly yeah
that kind of conversation are we opening
up the relationship no but it depends on
your your values
because a lot of women forget this and I
understand that you know words have
power and because you're reaffirming the
words that it might mean something but
you have to remember when it comes to
monogamy men conform to a woman's
reproductive strategy your reproductive
strategy is more keyed towards monogamy
whilst as a scattergun so what you're
actually asking a man to do is go
against his own biological impulses to
cater to you so it's actually unfair to
ask that and expect that when you're
more naturally catered to babe that way
when a man isn't this one when you're
having kids when you're having kids it
might be like cool we're monogamous
right like it's just us too but then
afterwards maybe once the kids have fled
the home you then might want to open up
that conversation and be like cool like
shall we open it
so would you be okay to have an open
relationship then I think I would
consider it yeah
I have I have a question you know she's
a feminist sir no it's not even about
being a feminist it's just like my
personal like what I'm okay with like so
yeah I think I would too I haven't been
in a 20-year relationship so I can't
tell you you know until I've got you
just open both ways okay I think if we'd
had kids been together for a long time
yeah serious I try it yeah kids are no
kids I will get my immune system will
shut down I'll die on the sport bro I
don't know I think like if we've been
together if I got like I've got married
tomorrow if we had kids imagine I'm like
I'm like 50 whatever and we're like
because thing is like the whole marriage
thing I'm like well sometimes you might
want to just explore yeah and to be
honest like I don't um
baby I missed you it's like a Will and
Jaden yeah
someone's younger and more so I'll tell
you what I try to I think it comes to an
arrogant place because I think if she's
with me and she's the one that she's
chosen then she ain't finding better
than me way so it's almost like her
going to another Garden
no but what I mean I'm talking like
that's what I said after kids and
everything I'm saying if we've been
together
after kids and age and all of that she's
with she may be with you out of loyalty
not because your sex is good no no
that's not what I'm saying that's not
what I'm saying because you're saying
that she may not find better than you no
no no no I'm saying better me as a
package like yeah but that's after she's
had kids and they're a lot older yeah
when basically her venues her value's
gone down
I said these are the conditions
you're gonna find her brother that's 20
years old oh yeah that's gonna slam her
up and he probably looked like you when
he was younger maybe and you're going to
see him I'm gonna think right nah [ __ ]
that I don't honestly I think at that
point like that happened I real I don't
think I would care because I'd be like
well if we want to both explore let's
explore can't find a 20 year old so yeah
honestly I feel like if if my husband
let me let me explore that's the end of
the relationship for me I'm serious yeah
yeah I think he's like he no longer
feels love for me he no longer cares
about me she don't want to that's how
I'd want to be territorial yeah that's
how I feel yeah well I'm an exception I
think a lot of the time is the decision
you know not the actual act I think it's
the deceit the deceit yeah like you're
going into the relationship saying I'm
going to be um
and then and then you go and do
something different like just be open
and Inspire it like yeah and come into
relationship I'm not promising again
girls will say this and it's all well
and good saying it but in act acting it
out it doesn't work
that's the thing I've ever heard a girl
saying as soon as what you said I
remember being talking to a woman at
work and she's like she's been with her
boyfriend for 14 years and they're due
to get married and I just put into a
problem just poke calls I thought you
know he's probably cheated on you a few
times she goes listen I know but he's
never he's never brought that problem
home I think and I don't know about it
I'm happy so as long as I remain happy
and I don't know and I never see it I'm
okay with what he does but as a mature
woman's mind I think that most women
don't go in there thinking oh yeah this
guy is just for me I don't think this is
not what you just said that you have to
have that conversation yeah
have to have that conversation like so
why is having the conversation a bad
thing or why does it have to be like
it's not realistic because most people
don't want honesty like let's just come
on let's just be ready we don't I I
don't care I would want to know yeah
with other people yeah
so I 100 I have a question
um so you you you're you're single moms
right do you feel like it's fair to
accept accept monogamy
um or to expect monogamy from someone
when you've given someone else a child
so they're not getting the youth and
like the Purity that they want I don't
remember I don't agree with your beliefs
so obviously I'm gonna say no I would
say don't pick me in the first place
yeah yeah oh I didn't realize you had
kids too yeah I have one child oh do you
me yeah okay so um yeah no
okay I think it depends on the guy
doesn't it like because if he's like
actually too fair if you said no then
fine but I think the higher value a man
is the more likely a woman is going to
accept that but if he's like just some
average if you're gonna accept it you're
gonna accept that anyway not because
you've got kids not because that's what
that's why I say no I think if a woman's
gonna accept that she's gonna accept
that but I think most women do accept it
I'm saying like how do most
relationships start nowadays
situationships side chicks
um like if you're in a situationship
like that's how most relationships start
is like talking okay and so I'm saying
like like most girls start that's what
you're starting as I won't say me
talking to someone automatically makes
me this I would think okay okay would
you say the majority of the time sex
comes first to relationships which are
six definitely okay so when when you're
having sex with someone you're not
exclusive what are a side chick I'm
having sex with someone that I'm seeing
yeah but I'm saying like he's also
sleeping with other people so exactly so
I agree with you on that that I think
you'll be very delusional to meet a guy
today and the first time you've slept
with him you think you're the only
person he's sleeping with at that moment
because you're just you've just come
into the picture I don't know if I like
you so he as in he's thinking that I
don't know if I like you I'm just seeing
where this goes and obviously you've
allowed me to enter your sexual
experience so I'm also going to
experience this while I'm here but the
sex is not gonna determine if I'm gonna
be with you that's why I'm that's why
you should be selective for you to sleep
and and when you allow him to access
yeah but like the point is you still
start off as a side chick
s
is what there's many chicks
for you to be a side you're going to
have a main right you have a main chick
and then you understand and that's what
you can only be that yes you can never
be the main one of his side chicks is
the main chick at one point in time
she might not have the title right but
he has a favorite he has a number one
draft pick
you know what though I think I think in
regards to the question about
to monogamy when you've had a child
I would say
universally if a woman hasn't helped me
attain my high value status then she
can't expect monogamy from me um
she hasn't contributed to me I'm not I
don't if you have because you have to
remember and I always say this like
women are born of value whilst men have
to create their value if I've had to
work hard and strive and do what I need
to do to attain a certain world you're
buying into that lifestyle having done
nothing so the only thing you can give
to me is probably kids and whatnot and
again if I want to give you monogamy I
can but you can't expect it from me
because you haven't done anything to to
Warrant the last time but when you're 20
and or 21 or whatever and you start
building would you want to get into a
serious relationship really a lot of men
and I said this on the show as well it's
context um for guys who were in the late
20s building their foundations or set
their foundations they want someone to
contribute to their lifestyle
women that you're looking for a guy
who's already made obviously if you're
going for a guy who's 21 22 23 you
should expect a young boy's mentality
yeah I have a question for you go on
would you keep that same mindset for a
woman who hasn't helped you contribute
haven't helped contribute oh sorry do
you have the same mindset for a lady who
hasn't helped to contribute to get you
to where the level you're at now
um but she doesn't have a child
yeah you have the same mindset yeah yeah
he said that in general yeah because
pearly was asking about yeah
University but I mean the point the
point is that men like are compromising
on their mating strategy but not getting
their mating strategy fulfilled in
return and what is that so they're
they're amazing strategies they don't
want to pass on resources to another
man's kid like that's why that's why
they're repulsed by hoes that's why
they're they're repulsed by like other
people's children
it's like a natural so so women want to
lock down and get commitment from the
highest value guy they can we're men
they want Purity and youth and they want
to know that the kids are theirs so they
get neither and we get what we want so
are you in a relationship
and anybody that you get with from now
are you going to be faithful I haven't
I'm close I get high value status in it
so I'm still in the very I'm still very
much in my building but yeah yeah I met
someone now and I'm able to build to
attain that level then you deserve it
exclusively can I ask you a question
okay the going was intense but let's say
let's let's say you were someone who was
willing to date someone who had a child
and you're in your growing your building
status and she was happy and willing to
build with you
would you be faithful to her
so I've accepted woman for kids yeah
obviously in a normal circumstance I
said that would happen anyway but if it
did and you know what let me just say I
think never say never type thing yet but
yeah I think what what plays into my
idea of that is again it's the fact I'm
Nigerian and I know that would be even
but you know it's so funny you say that
yeah but in in Nigeria Nigerian men in
Nigeria accept girls with kids more than
here my parents are on smoke okay I know
for a fact oh does it come from like a
cultural thing so what I've watched my
own experience my mothers wouldn't want
yeah
from my experience as a single mother
right I get more smoke here than I get
in Nigeria really and I think and I
think a big part of that a big part of
that is because back back in Nigeria uh
a man who
who took on another woman's child that
wasn't his he gets a lot of honor and
respect for that yeah yeah yeah probably
like back in the day it used to happen
but because it's almost like oh wow he's
the man who not only is he supplying for
his own kids but for someone else's
there came a lot of respect for that so
I think it was more regarded in high
regard but it's not regarded like that
today like in Nigeria you can say that
I'll be like oh I've got kids they only
think daily joke that they make an idea
is like you know you London kids like
London girls like to have kids quickly
that is it but they don't they don't say
like oh you're less of a woman but they
even find women with kids a lot more
serious
very much say a lot of the
responsibility if the if the family
doesn't go well a lot the responsibility
falls on the woman like it's the woman's
fault if anything goes wrong what if the
marriage doesn't work
it's one of the reasons she's scared
that anything would happen in the
marriage obviously everything is good
but if it was she would say the problem
falls on a woman that's very still very
much so the case like obviously modern
day women now you know so mad I I agree
with you I I as much as is is
um a hard pill to swallow
majority of the marriages that don't
last is because of the woman not like
she was the problem but she just wasn't
willing to show the blame no she was
just not willing to continue because
like if if I was to sit here and start
dissecting my marriage you'd be like but
you could have worked it through it you
know what I mean like yeah yeah but and
this is why I say that if someone if you
if you one of the issues or the mistakes
I made I didn't date a bad boy I'm not
interested in Bad Boys I was it wasn't a
thing for me I did I dated the quite I
was married to a quiet guy but what I
didn't pay attention to and that was
lack of knowledge is attributes
mannerisms how you'll raise Family
Values all of that those were my
problems it wasn't oh he was cheating or
um you know he he was we just did it I
was just fed up it was that our values
didn't work together so that's why it's
my fault because you could turn around
and say that why didn't you pick up
those things things I wasn't wise enough
to pick up on those things can I can I
ask did you leave sorry yeah
did you left sorry yeah okay first yeah
would you ever get back with him
no and you know we're so mad yet you
remember the last time we came he said I
don't uh he didn't I do so much so in a
figure of speech right when the last
time he came he said that um part of a
marriage um as a woman you're meant to
for your kids you're meant to stay in a
marriage but I remember I said it I said
the main reason why I left was because
of my kids because when you look at my
kids now they're a lot calmer the
teachers don't complain about them when
I was the teachers used to complain a
lot about my children's Behavior just
them being unsettled just being but as
soon as I facilitated structure they're
fine is that because you and your your
husband was showing the troubles in your
relationship this was even after we
broke up and he had access to the kids
as soon as that access was no longer
there they were a lot more settled I but
don't get me wrong I I am so scared
raising my boys because I'm a woman
do you know what I mean so like even
little things like when my son comes
upstairs and he's crying even though I
want to hug him because I don't want to
make the mistakes I believe some parents
have made on their sons I have to be
Stern you know what I mean and I I get
scared that am I confusing this boy that
he need a woman is meant to be
aggressive
I respect that because yeah
do you get what I'm saying it's like how
do you teach him because a lot of women
don't even take that into account a lot
of women just they do the the motherly
thing which is just to like Cottage yeah
because when I have a second question
would you take him back if there was no
other man on the planet no I won't be on
my own I've started to even though I
don't like it and I'm praying to God it
doesn't happen but I'm starting to
have that 10 that you may be on your own
for a long time
um do you think you'll have 2.5 million
saved up to retire
I think being sometime you're 60. yes if
that's what I wanted I will have what I
want okay yeah I I one thing about me
and anyone will tell you I work hard I'm
I am a grinder well women like like
because the thing is
you're you're probably in a small
percentage of women that make that
amount of money but a lot of women will
be homeless in that position yeah and I
don't think they're really educated
about that because I mean I know there's
like government benefits here but you
don't know tomorrow they could take them
away yeah yeah and be rely on that
can I ask you a question to the ladies
in the room so did you want to do
something oh no
um so different shift
um obviously women earn their own money
and they earn good money nowadays right
so women have almost in certain ways
adopted the traditional masculine
positions that men have taken
historically
but then a lot of women will still say
that they don't want to provide for a
man so it's almost like they've taken
the position of a man but they don't
want to take the responsibility that
comes with that position I just want to
know why do you guys think that is or do
you think that's even a fair statement
to say
um I think
no I think it's just again just like
subjective you know
um I've been in a position where I
supported my man for like two years
would you have been happy to do that if
you stayed together like for the
duration of your relationship
yeah if I had to for sure but like I
think again
there is that Natural Energy exchange
that needs to take place
um
obviously like I would probably have
that conversation but like hey you know
but like why but what I'm trying to say
is like if you're the person in the
relationship who is earning more right
why would you have to be like okay we
need to have a conversation about this
why could you just be like okay well I'm
just going to be providing for the
relationship because I feel like there's
like an energy of like resentment that
might come up and I guess what I'm
asking is where does that come from
because I agree yeah um honestly I don't
know
um which did you say it's entitlement no
did you still find that man attractive
yes yeah yeah
I think a woman can do it if she thinks
it's temporary yes yeah and the thing is
like we were we were building like
together so I was involved in the dream
he was involved in the dream and we were
building his dream you know and so I
supported that 100 so I couldn't also
gone I could never be the provider of my
of my home never I don't want to
I think it's confusing for the children
it's confusing for me
I like this is not my wrong I always
have like why is he not working is it is
he staying home and it's not that he's
not working right but it's like let's
say for example your chosen career paths
right you're earning 80k he's earning
30k right and you want to live a certain
lifestyle but in order to live that
lifestyle like you have to be uh have
the financial burden of let's say 90 of
the relationship
then that's fine because you want that
lifestyle right like the woman wants
their life but you would be okay you'd
like you would be okay provided for him
yeah if the woman wants the lifestyle
then you're gonna have to the woman's
gonna have to uphold it otherwise she
would have to come down a level but she
has to uphold it for herself and for him
yeah so you know the way men have
traditionally brought women up to their
lifestyle you're doing the same for your
man like but I feel like most women
would not want to do that like you said
like a lot of time if a woman's here
she's like I want a guy who's here or
above hashtag hypergamy
you know what um Auntie said she said
that um last time she was on the show I
don't know if you you guys probably I
don't know if you've seen Clips with her
she's like this um 50 something year old
Auntie that's just like yeah she's so
funny and she said that
um I I knew a couple that like where he
worked and she worked and she would just
come home and give the money to her
husband all these women say that they
can't trust the man with the money but
they trust them with their bodies and my
body's a lot more valuable than some
money
that's true but I can I can um if me and
my husband are working I'm happy to put
my money in a joint account for her and
I give it to him though I don't think
the kind of man I'll be with would want
it to be seen like that he would
probably just I think in my head I could
be wrong but I just I I wouldn't mind in
my home is we sit down we plan and he
says you are only allowed to spend this
amount of your money you have to put the
rest in savings I'm okay with that so
you you don't mind being the constant
because essentially even though you're
putting into one pot you're the
breadwinner no no no we're saying that
we're talking about how we manage our
money so he he he I was I won't use the
world the world control you know we
don't like saying words but I wouldn't
use the word control I'll say but he has
a final say on how I spend I'm okay with
that if he says with you earning more
no even if he was earning more no this
is
I'm just making a comment what she said
about managing money
so so you like let's say you earn 100K I
don't know what you're let's just say
you're in 100K he makes 55.
he's a hard-working man he's a fireman I
wouldn't be with someone who's a fireman
though
why shout out to the firemen but it's
not
why not like that that could be like a
masculine guy it's a good job no no no
no no see
let's even leave the money side of
things I I don't want to be thinking I
hope he's okay where he is oh okay I
can't deal with it
I've been a police officer all of that I
I you know I respect women let's say
plumber okay let's let's change it to
plumber it wasn't about they make money
anyway so no 55. you know you know what
I'm I'm a mum so we do have to make
certain like the truth of the matter is
we have to
compromise a little bit I could be with
a plumber who's on 50K if he had a plan
to not always be on that 50k but it's
hard now this isn't build a bomb the
same building I was just about to say I
was just about to say that hard
we date potential yeah yeah and hope
yeah so it's like yeah but so the answer
then no no no yeah I don't think that's
a mistake I have a problem with this
though because a lot of women seem to do
is quite a lot is that every woman wants
a man to to be rich and successful no I
don't know okay he he never planned okay
sorry sorry I know I'm into I'm into
sorry but
I think it's based on your age if I'm
dating a guy he's like if I decide to
get younger I cannot expect him to be on
certain salaries but if I'm dating a guy
and I think I prefer to date guys who
are like 35 and up I should be seeing
your progression by now you shouldn't be
I would or could or Shoulda yeah but if
I date the other end of the age group
then I can't expect you to have it all
together 50k is still tough for some
people no but I'm saying my point is for
some people right but I'm saying like
like 50k is still taught I couldn't find
it exactly but it's okay but like 20 30
of income or do you think your your top
20 30 of women yeah what financially no
okay what men value is that one serve
except in my fate but what one thing is
I I know my I know my personal I know my
trades and I think as a woman you have
to know your behavior I don't think
that's a problem I think and this is why
I pulled it up because a lot of women
seem to have this I don't want to find a
guy's potential whatever whatever the
age if a guy's making around 55k we know
the statistics around what percentage of
men make that money yeah how unrealistic
is most women's perspective on okay so I
I agree that some women think they
should have certain things because they
see other women having it but you don't
know what those women are doing to get
what they what they have I.E either
they're working hard or the things they
accept in their home you can't even
accept one percent of it so unless
unless you have full knowledge on
people's situations don't ask for what
you don't know what's the minute making
50 bags well the moment I know they are
no no okay okay
but that's why I say that for me I can't
be with a guy who's on 50K because I
know my traits I know my behavior and
unfortunately I will start to resent him
and I won't be happy so why would I make
another man's life miserable because I
want to get in a relationship would you
would you rather be alone or be with a
guy that makes significantly less you
know logically it makes sense for me to
be with a guy that has money because
I'll be paying less than one person no
but I'm asking if like if that was your
two choices I'm just
um
Grace no you wouldn't what if it's on
50K you like companionship no no I like
companionship but I know what I'm saying
if if he's going to be on 50K all his
life yeah yeah but imagine this what you
earn yeah and then you add 50k to that
okay or nothing or you don't add
anything and this is what I always talk
about about this 50k or these amounts
right and this is why I don't like
talking about it because I think it's
unfair let's say me and my husband now
decide to go on go halves right we go 50
50. he's on 50K I'm on 100 and whatever
he's feeling that money he's putting
down more than I am right but because of
the kind of man I want to be with he's
probably going to say I have to at least
contribute half he is gonna within his
within himself and then I'll come
tomorrow and go babes when are we going
on holiday he's thinking bruh I'm
already paying half you know I want to
go on holiday again so you'd actually
rather be by yourself I'd rather be with
a guy who is working towards I don't
know what she said I don't know that's
what he said I'm going to answer the
question no no I'm answering the
question I'd rather I'd rather stay on
my own and wait for someone that I can
see
yeah but I think it's like easy to say
that when you're still young young and
attractive but like when you're when
you're 60 and maybe like maybe the clock
starts I think when you're older anyway
you don't you like I said we're talking
about this when you're older I feel like
when you get married and all that you're
not marrying for help or financial
you're marrying for companionship yeah
but that's that's what I'm saying like
like women as women I don't think we
think about the second half of our lives
like we're all gonna live probably to be
90. so and your looks are gone at what
if you're lucky you might get 50 but
like you're no guys really checking for
50 year olds so like what are we gonna
do the second half of our Lives
I think is it fair to say is it fair to
say that because arguably you know
you you you're still very much
competitive in the market you're like
okay well I'm still gonna I'm still
gonna maintain these standards because I
believe it's still very much achievable
but then I don't know the truth you
might be like okay maybe I should
actually focus on having a companion as
opposed to how much you own yeah my
needs will be different then right
because yeah so right now my needs are
different but I think my beliefs and my
way of thinking is based on my traumas
and experience not that I'm still
holding my traumas or whatever I've let
it go I'm I'm good but right now I'm I'm
so stubborn in my mindset of I don't
want to make certain mistakes so I'd
rather be patient because I think I was
really impatient I think a lot of the
the situations I found myself is my lack
of patience so now I'm trying patience
do you understand so this is the
approach do you think anything happens
like you accomplish anything through
patience like do you understand like
yeah like wouldn't you say success is
hard work and like like getting what you
want you have to work at it and go for
it rather than just like hoping it comes
I'm just I'm just talking about what
I've been through Germany and I think
some of the things that I think maybe if
I was patient more patient I might not
have gotten married to the person I got
married to if I was more patient to pay
attention to the certain things I would
have picked up certain things and
certain things wouldn't happen that's
why I'm saying I'm taking on patience
during this journey yeah okay
um I think I'm gonna close out the show
um I'm gonna Read Super chats in a
second
um but everyone think of final thoughts
you can tell people where to find you
whatever
um did you did you have something to say
I thought you're gonna say something
okay
um okay Starscream Abba and preach just
released a video today on women's
expectations for men and these women
from Ohio were saying 100K to 400k is a
minimum that's two percent of the
population Russell Warren like War play
marriage causes divorce if a guy builds
women will complain he works too much
women divorce Rich guys because he's not
Chad Starscream ask the ladies if a
couple are both career professionals and
they decide to have kid kids is it fair
to their partner to give up their career
for their kids during early stages of
development explain why follow if you
swallow
the question for the baby mama would you
let another man Discipline Your Child
Maurice Pearl where are you finding
these deluded Nigerians Nigerian men
will say anything to so they can Clap
the cheeks mgtow by Logic men don't want
a 35 year old masculine woman men are
straight 95 percent of men are not gay
we want femininity wake up Starscream
ABC these chicks have had more than one
two three I'ma dress up as the word
accountability for Halloween and chase
women
don't give me an idea
um Russell Wallace Warren I appreciate
the discussion Lawrence Bullock the one
thing I disagree with the manosphere is
that Marion man shouldn't cheat just
like married women
um Russell Warren Domo our jitto um Mr
Roberto Russell Warren first drafts are
terrible Ernest Hemingway Lawrence
Bullock how is it that drug dealers in
game oh I read this one already
um Let me refresh it real quick guys
make sure you like the video
um that is the most important metric
that you YouTube uses to push out these
live so make sure you like it thank you
for all the donations they are going
towards getting blessing in 8k camera I
want you to see the freckles on my face
when I do reaction videos so
um yeah send send donations
um dejeon savior get her that GMO sized
eggplant she'll go bankrupt wow
get a big woolly
[Music]
um well this was a fun panel so thank
you guys all for coming on
um why don't we go around any final
thoughts or start start over there and
then go around
um I don't have any final thoughts maybe
um but yeah you could just find me on
Milford honey podcast Instagram yeah
they throw lit shows I had so much fun
um final thoughts I probably say it's
the original thing was you know our
modern women lost or whatever and I
would say the first thing I would say is
um if you're looking for a relationship
start prioritizing The Men Who show
levels of commitment as opposed to the
guy who's big and shiny that
personality basically
um where can you find me Maxi underscore
J and MILF and honey podcast
final thoughts
um I think men need to make better
decisions with who they're sleeping with
yeah but
um obviously modern day women we still
need to make better decisions for
ourselves and for our futures as well so
yeah
um
so you can find me at goddess.intentions
underscore that's my spiritual brand
um final thoughts I think that men and
women just have to understand each other
more
um we have to communicate better
um they don't teach us these things in
school and so we have to educate
ourselves
and yeah that's why the work of Pearl
and kit is like so incredible and thank
you guys for inviting me and being here
is really good yeah thanks for coming
um you can find me on Gracie Bakery
on Instagram or MILF and honey podcast
um I really enjoyed today compared to
the last one
um I think my last thoughts I think us
women need to um humble a little bit
more
um it's a bit it's a hard pill to
swallow even for myself but if we want
certain happiness there's certain things
we're gonna have to accept
okay um you can find me on Instagram on
longer legs that's over Z dot IG
um and I think in terms of like
platforms like this the best thing to do
is listen to the information let the
seeds sink in and don't take anything
personally because when you remove the
ego you actually have a chance to learn
yeah and this is a really good um
this is a really good opportunity that a
lot of people wouldn't have had like
maybe 10 years ago about the access of
the internet so people are very quick to
shoot their shot but um actually that
just takes time to digest information I
think we could maybe
you know move through a better Society
um
I think the main problem of society is
that people generally lack
self-awareness so when you truly become
self-aware you become cognizant of your
behaviors and how you behave around
other people now one book I'd recommend
is the Power of Now
and one of the things he says that the
reason why negativity exists is because
people operate from an unconscious state
of mind and when you're operating from
an uncreative unconscious state of mind
you're using habits some habits are
positive some are negative but because
we only only cause 95 of what we do is
through habits only five percent five
percent of the time unconscious we're
often making the wrong decisions which
negatively impact other people so if we
raise our level of Consciousness to
understand that what we're doing may be
negatively impact other people we create
a better Society by and large so people
need to stop being egotistic needs to
understand that your behaviors are as
much as big as part of the problem as
other peoples and again just raise your
State of Consciousness so you're not
making bad decisions
ask for where you can find me obviously
United the domino effect podcast
um but if you want to come on the show
hit me up
um who's on the score Eddie underscore
and yeah hit me up in the DMs
did you go yeah yeah I'm sure
okay guys uh make sure you like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel also check out our membership
tiers as you know first tier gets you in
the chat second tier you get the Discord
and the behind the scenes Vlogs third
tier you connect with me on social media
and fourth tier you get a one-on-one
call with me once a month I really if
you want to start a YouTube channel I'm
telling you I am like the queen of
YouTube every person that I've worked
with ten thousand twenty thousand thirty
thousand Subs like I I kill YouTube I'm
not even gonna lie to you
um also
um like it's a steal like honestly
anyways
um don't forget to like the video
subscribe to the channel on your way out
help us get to 500k and we will talk to
you next time